ministre monsieur le rapporteur mes
chers collègues nous poursuivons ce
matin les auditions de la mission
d'information que notre commission a
décidé de constituer sur la création du
fond Marianne la sélection des projets
subventionnés le contrôle de leur
exécution et les résultats obtenus au
regard des objectifs du fond cette
mission d'information a obtenu du Sénat
de bénéficier des prérogatives des
commissions d'enquêtes nous entendons
donc ce matin madame Marlène Schiappa
secrétaire d'État auprès de la première
ministre chargé de l'économie sociale et
solidaire et de la vie associative en sa
qualité d'anciennes ministres délégué
auprès du ministre intérieur chargé de
la citoyenneté du 6 juillet 2020 au 20
mai 2022
comme vous le savez madame la ministre
nous avons entendu ces dernières
semaines de nombreux acteurs
administratifs et associatif ainsi que
votre ancien directeur de cabinet afin
de comprendre la manière dont le fond
Marianne a été créé la procédure ayant
conduit à la sélection des projets les
conditions de suivi de leur mise en
oeuvre ainsi que les résultats obtenus
au regard des responsabilités qui
étaient les vôtres au moment de la
création et du lancement du fond
Marianne votre audition est
particulièrement attendue pour éclaircir
l'ensemble de ces points
avant de vous céder la parole si vous le
souhaitez bien sûr pour un bref propos
introductif je dois vous rappeler qu'un
faux témoignage devant une commission
d'enquête et passible de sanctions
pénales qui peuvent aller selon les
circonstances de 3 à 7 ans
d'emprisonnement et de 45000 à 100000
euros d'amende je vous invite à prêter
serment de dire toute la vérité rien que
la vérité levait la main droite et dites
je le jure
merci je vous laisse donc à présent la
parole pour un bref
introduction s'il vous plaît merci merci
monsieur le Président à monsieur le
rapporteur mesdames et Messieurs les
sénatrices et sénateurs je serai bref
mais je veux d'abord bien évidemment
vous remercier de cette audition devant
la mission d'information devant cette
commission d'enquête je vais tâcher
humblement et dans la limite bien sûr
des éléments dont je dispose de vous
aider à établir une chronologie mais
aussi la matérialité des faits vu de ma
fenêtre c'est à dire la fenêtre du
ministre et donc je suis heureuse de
pouvoir répondre pour la première fois
un certain nombre de questions
particulières en dehors du bruit ou des
commentaires ou des supputations qui ont
pu être émises en dehors bien sûr de
cette commission et de pouvoir être
aussi factuel que possible donc je vais
tâcher de vous aider en cela je reste
sans doute pas réponse à tout je me suis
pas omnisciente sur ce sujet ni sur les
autres d'ailleurs
mais les enseignements et la maternité
de certains faits eu égard au travail du
rapport de l'igéa nous nous aiderons
j'imagine en cela je vais vous dire
d'ores et déjà monsieur le Président et
monsieur le rapporteur que vous m'avez
écrit hier soir pour me demander d'avoir
accès aux archives des mails échangés
entre mon cabinet et moi-même bien
évidemment je donne mon accord pour que
vous puissiez avoir accès à ces archives
donc je vous fais une réponse écrite qui
va vous parvenir là aujourd'hui et qui
vous permettra d'avoir accès à
l'ensemble de ces messages bien
évidemment je veux très brièvement
rappeler le rôle de chacun de manière
habituelle dans un fonctionnement
ministériel vous avez le ministre qui
impulse des politiques publiques
qui représentent également ces
politiques publiques qui en est
comptable devant bien sûr le Parlement
je suis là aujourd'hui mais devant tous
les exercices que vous connaissez devant
le Parlement mais aussi devant les
citoyens soit de manière directe soit de
manière indirecte par l'INT on va dire
des médias c'est le rôle du ministre le
rôle de l'administration c'est la mise
en œuvre de ces politiques publiques
impulsées par le ministre la mise en
oeuvre et le suivi et le ministre en
cela s'appuie sur la confiance qu'il a
dans les collaborateurs ce qu'il a
choisi ou ce qu'il a trouvé en arrivant
et s'appuie sur la sincérité des
déclarations des rapports mais aussi des
comptes fait par les partenaires et par
les associations brièvement peut-être
remettre le contexte de la création de
ce fond Marianne même si j'imagine que
nous y reviendrons je rappelais que le
contexte c'est celui de ce que certains
experts dont Julie Kepel notamment
appellent le djihadisme d'atmosphère ça
veut dire que des terroristes désormais
ne se radicalisent plus en allant dans
des endroits comme précédemment certains
dans certains kebab ou certaines
mosquées qui étaient radicalisées qui
étaient des lieux d'endoctrinement mais
ce radicalise sur internet en consultant
des sites des plateformes ou des réseaux
sociaux dans le contexte les
spécialistes recommandent de lutter
contre ce terreau du terrorisme en
allant là où ce discours se porte c'est
à dire en ligne sur les réseaux sociaux
et il est donc décidé en ce qui nous
concerne par une décision du Conseil de
défense de faire appel notamment à des
acteurs de la société civile pour
soutenir ce discours républicain comme
ça se fait dans d'autres pays comme le
Royaume-Uni et le fond Marianne il
s'inscrit dans cette action globale ce
n'est pas je tiens à dire l'entièreté de
la politique publique menée pour lutter
contre la radicalisation je veux le
rappeler il y a une politique plus
globale je vous en fais pas la liste
exhaustive mais simplement mentionner
l'ucdr dont on parlera peut-être la
lutte contre la haine en ligne
l'ouverture de Pharos 24 heures sur 24
et les dispositions législatives que
vous connaissez parfaitement pour en
tant que parlementaire les avoir nourris
ou en tout cas avoir pris part au débat
je veux dire aussi mais j'imagine que
nous y reviendrons que le budget du fond
Marianne
est une ligne budgétaire du FIPD donc du
ministère de l'Intérieur je sais que
vous le savez mais je tiens à être
factuel dans ce propos liminaire bref ce
n'est à aucun moment une cagnotte je
l'ai entendu ici et là l'état bien
évidemment ne lance pas de cagnotte au
profit des familles de victimes de
terrorisme il n'y a pas de cagnotte il
n'y a pas de collecte de fonds c'est une
ligne budgétaire du ministère de
l'intérieur et en l'espèce du FIPD
je veux dire également que il y a des
questions aujourd'hui très légitimes qui
se posent et je salue j'avais appelé de
mes vœux dans le respect de la
séparation des pouvoirs l'ouverture de
cette commission d'enquête je la salue
et je m'en réjouis parce qu'elle permet
justement par des auditions longues
précises par des témoignages parfois par
la mise en lumière de contradiction
d'avérer un certain nombre de
dysfonctionnements le rapport de l'igéa
d'ailleurs commandé à la demande du
gouvernement et réalisé au ministère de
l'Intérieur il met en oeuvre il met en
lumière pardon des dysfonctionnements
qui sont avérés qui sont documentés et
nous allons je pense y revenir mais je
veux dire ici qu'il y a je profite de ce
trop polymère pour le dire il y a aussi
il y a surtout dans leur grande majorité
des associations qui mènent un travail
remarquable pour défendre la laïcité
pour lutter contre l'islamisme la
radicalisation ou les discours dit
séparatiste de manière globale
aujourd'hui beaucoup des acteurs du fond
qui sont des associations que vous avez
pu auditionner donc vous avez pu
constater le sérieux pour la grande
majorité d'entre elles sont brocardées
insultés pour certaines même menacées de
morts comme beaucoup d'acteurs qui
s'engagent contre la radicalisation
contre l'islamisme et je veux dire ici
mon soutien à ces associations et à ces
personnalités qui s'engagent et
également aux agents du cipdr passé et
actuelles qui dans leur immense majorité
mènent au ministère de l'Intérieur un
travail difficile avec avec beaucoup de
sérieux pour conclure je voudrais dire
que votre votre retour d'expérience et
les recommandations j'imagine que vous
formulerez à l'issue de cette commission
d'enquête seront particulièrement
intéressants bien évidemment pour chacun
en tant que citoyen pour moi en tant que
secrétaire d'État qui à ce jour suis
chargé de la vie associative ce que vous
direz sur la manière dont on doit ou ne
doit pas attribuer des subventions par
exemple aux associations sur la jusqu'où
on doit aller dans le contrôle de
l'attribution des subventions ce sera
extrêmement intéressant je disais pour
moi en tant que que membre du
gouvernement mais aussi je pense pour
tous les décideurs publics parce que les
décisions en tout cas les
recommandations qui seront les
enseignements en tout cas qui seront
tirés à l'issue de cette commission
d'enquête et bien elle poseront des
questions
que je pose et auxquelles je n'ai pas
forcément la réponse mais demain est-ce
qu'un décideur public est-ce qu'un
responsable politique est-ce qu'un maire
par exemple peut faire confiance à son
administration ou à des associations
sans craindre d'être blâmé lorsqu'il y a
des dysfonctionnements internes à ces
associations est-ce qu'un responsable
politique est fondé à passer des
commandes à son administration et plus
important encore dirais-je que cela
demain comment peut-on poursuivre cette
politique publique nécessaire de lutte
contre la radicalisation et contre le
terreau du sans que la peur d'être
amalgamé à ce dossier
désormais dit du fond Marianne puisse
exister je veux dire pour conclure que
cette politique publique en ce qui
concerne le gouvernement puisque je suis
auditionnée à ce titre et bien elle se
poursuit je n'en suis plus en charge
depuis plus d'un an j'ai tout confiance
dans mes successeur mais aussi dans
l'administration telle qu'elle est
constituée actuellement et dans
l'ensemble des parties prenantes pour
continuer à mener ce combat qui est un
combat essentiel nécessaire à notre pays
et qui est un maillon de la chaîne de la
lutte contre la radicalisation et le
terrorisme mais qui est je crois un
maillon essentiel qui doit absolument
perdurer je suis à votre entière
disposition pour répondre à toutes vos
questions je vous remercie merci merci
madame la ministre d'avoir tenu un
propos relativement court en
introduction je donne la parole tout de
suite au rapport
à propos qu'on en sait en effet merci
madame la ministre vous avez évoqué dans
votre propos introductif interne en tous
les cas qui n'a jamais été utilisé dans
notre commission le terme de cagnotte
je pense qu'il n'a pas sa raison d'être
qu'il n'y ait aucune ambiguïté et je
vais en profiter puisque vous avez donné
quelques explications sur le
fonctionnement du fond
il n'a pas échappé évidemment aux
membres de la commission des finances
réunie en commission d'information
commission d'enquête et peut-être dire
quelques mots à l'attention de celles et
ceux qui nous écoutent vous l'avez dit
il y a aujourd'hui trois procédures sur
le dossier je vais l'appeler comme ça
du fond Marianne il y a une procédure en
cours avec un rapport partiel de
l'inspection générale de
l'administration il y a une procédure
une ouverture
d'une information du judiciaire par le
parquet national financier et puis une
commission d'enquête dont je rappelle
que elle est la forme la plus élaborée
du contrôle de l'action du gouvernement
qui est ouverte au Parlement
[Musique]
c'est peut-être un point de détail mais
pas nécessairement qu'est-ce qui a
présidé à ce choix du fond Marianne qui
la définit comment avez-vous procédé
merci à monsieur le rapporteur d'abord
pour être très clair vis-à-vis de votre
propos introductif à vous-même enfin si
j'ai bien compris je n'ai à aucun moment
remis en cause l'existence de la
commission c'est pas moi que ça
s'adressait
tout le monde n'a pas le même niveau
d'information très bien je vous remercie
monsieur le rapporteur alors le fond
Mariana je vous le disais en conseil de
défense il y a une décision qui est
prise de faire appel et de mobiliser les
acteurs de ce qu'on appelle alors
contredours républicain je comprends que
cette appellation porte à différentes
appréciations mais en tout cas c'est
l'appellation qui lui est donné à ce
moment-là ou en tout cas de porter un
discours en défense des valeurs de la
République en ligne cette décision est
prise un certain nombre d'acteurs de la
société civile sont mobilisées pour
faire en sorte justement de mettre en
oeuvre cette décision et nous avons avec
mon directeur de cabinet Monsieur le
Préfet j'allais que vous avez auditionné
nous bénéficions il m'informe du fait
que nous avons obtenu un arbitrage
favorable de Matignon pour reporter des
crédits non utilisés du FIPD de l'année
précédente donc la ligne budgétaire du
fond interministériel de prévention de
la délinquance et de la radicalisation
même donc du FIP des r nous bénéficions
d'après les vraiment dont je dispose il
m'envoie un message pour me dire que
nous bénéficions de 2 millions et demi
d'euros de reports de crédit et donc
comme nous avons à la fois une
demande de mobiliser les acteurs de la
société civile pour porter ce discours
et cette ligne budgétaire dont nous
bénéficions nous décidons pour plus de
lisibilité de mettre en oeuvre une
appellation de fond Marianne qui
regroupe sous le biais d'un appel à
projet d'un AAP ces acteurs de la
société civile que le ministère
viendrait soutenir dans leur action de
discours républicain donc le nom de
Marianne est simplement un écho au
symbole de la République alors plusieurs
choses d'abord le nom Marianne c'est
j'apprends rien à personne l'allégorie
de la République c'est-à-dire je vais
dire un panneau Marianne au Sénat à
l'entrée une exposition sur la figure de
Marianne c'est une figure qu'on utilise
traditionnellement au ministère de
l'intérieur j'ai lancé plusieurs projets
qui ont le nom Marianne comme 109
Marianne ou les Mariannes de la
République et peut-être d'autres je suis
pas la seule le nom et couramment usité
c'était un nom par ailleurs qui était
important pour le cipdr qui avait un
moment le projet de lancer des réseaux
sociaux marianne.gouv et finalement le
nom république.gouv avait été retenu
mais on avait dans mes souvenirs en tout
cas je n'ai pas trace écrite mais dans
mes souvenirs il y a un consensus sur le
fait que quand on dit Marianne chacun
comprend qu'il s'agit de la République
et de défendre les valeurs de la
République c'est en tout cas comme ça
que je me souviens de ces échanges merci
vous vous avez évoqué à deux reprises
avoir fait le choix d'un sur le montant
d'un appel à projet pour ouvrir aux
partenariat avec le réseau associatif
pourquoi avoir eu recours un appel à
projet sachant que vous avez déjà des
acteurs implantés qui ont un
savoir-faire comment vous êtes-vous tenu
informé du processus et à quelles étapes
êtes-vous
intervenu pour obtenir des retours
d'information ou pour valider des
décisions
alors d'abord monsieur le rapporteur sur
le choix de l'appel à projet il y a un
échange entre mon directeur de cabinet
Monsieur le Préfet j'allais et moi-même
sur la manière justement de financer et
de soutenir financièrement au mieux les
acteurs de la société civile Monsieur le
Préfet j'allais me propose de passer par
un appel à projet en me disant tout à
fait conscient qu'aujourd'hui ça peut
paraître paradoxal à la lumière des
événements mais en disant que ce sera
plus transparent et plus équitable que
les subventions de gré à gré puisque
jusqu'à présent c'était des subventions
me semble-t-il de gré à gré du cipdr en
direction des associations nous avons
alors le sentiment que l'appel à projet
répond effectivement à cette demande
d'une part d'autre part qui permettra de
faire émerger de nouveaux acteurs qui
sont pas forcément encore
identifiés dans la sphère du cipdr et
donc nous prenons ensemble et j'assume
la décision de passer par un appel à
projet
ensuite il y a un comité de sélection
qui est mise en place avec des membres
de l'administration et des membres de
mon cabinet moi je n'interviens pas
personnellement je ne suis pas dans le
comité de sélection eu égard ce que je
rappelais dans mon propos introductif
les rôles de chacun mais pas du rôle du
ministre de faire de l'hymne générique
et d'ouvrir le capot pour regarder
l'ensemble des dossiers donc je ne suis
pas dans le comité de sélection en
revanche je suis tenue bien sûr informé
régulièrement par mon cabinet des
discussions qui peuvent exister autour
de l'attribution des subventions
je pense qu'on aura l'occasion d'y
revenir mais à ma connaissance
vous deviez faire partie du comité de
sélection
je n'en ai pas souvenir je n'ai pas de
trace dans mes éléments du fait que je
doive en faire partie en tout cas je
n'en fais pas partie c'est une
observation que je porte à la
connaissance de chacun
je relève dans l'explication que vous
venez de donner que vous avez vous dites
avoir suivi des conseils du préfet
Jallet votre directeur de cabinet à
l'époque
et vous dites pour l'appel à projet
étant conseiller comme une procédure
plus transparente et plus équitable je
mesure que vous utilisez à dessin ces
mots puisque ce sont exactement les
mêmes qui sont repris par l'Inspection
générale de l'administration pour
dénoncer le fait que la procédure était
ni transparente ni équitable donc je ne
sais pas si c'est un une manière pour
vous de répondre et de dire que il y a
eu erreur sur toute la ligne je sais pas
si vous voulez
aller un peu plus loin sur le sujet
parce que si vous démarrez vos propos en
expliquant que ce qui devait être plus
juste plus transparent et plus équitable
ne l'est pas de votre propre aveu enfin
déclaration et donc aveu c'est une
déclaration me semble-t-il importante
que vous faites à cet instant
ce n'est pas ce que j'ai dit d'abord moi
je n'ai pas d'appréciation à porter sur
le rapport de l'ijia c'est un rapport
qui a été mené avec le plus grand
sérieux par une inspection qui est
réputée pour son professionnalisme qui a
eu accès à des informations auxquelles
moi je n'ai pas accès puisque une fois
encore je ne suis pas omniscient dans ce
dossier j'étais ministre dans un temps
donné dans un temps limité je n'ai pas
interrogé les différents acteurs c'est
l'hygia qui a réalisé ce travail mais je
n'ai aucune raison de de contester la
conclusion de l'hygia et je n'ai non
plus je me paraisse reprendre votre
terme sur la porte aucun aveu à faire
dans la mesure où je n'ai pas pris à ce
comité pas pris part pardon à ce comité
de sélection
d'accord
en audition il nous a été indiqué
qu'avec votre arrivée en poste le 6
juillet 2020 le processus de décision du
moins pour l'attribution de certaines
subventions du FIPD
était passé en fait du secrétaire
général du
cipdr au cabinet au motif ce qui est en
audition que le périmètre de votre
ministère du secrétariat d'État était
parfaitement
identique à celui du cpdr ce qui voulait
dire que la signature le pouvoir de
décision
sortait des mains de l'administration
pour être aux mains exclusives du
pouvoir politique
comment expliquer vous ce changement
qu'elles en sont les motivations et
finalement qui participait concrètement
autour de vous avec vous au processus de
décision
je ne dirais pas du tout que les
décisions étaient remises exclusivement
aux mains du pouvoir politique et je ne
dirais pas non plus si vous me le
permettez que c'est parce que le
périmètre du ministère cadré avec le
périmètre du cipdr le périmètre du
ministère délégué était bien plus large
que celui du cpdr avec notamment la
question de l'intégration des étrangers
de l'accélération des délais pour les
cartes d'identité et beaucoup d'autres
missions en dehors du cpdr en revanche
ce qui est juste c'est que avec la
création d'un ministère délégué à la
citoyenneté pour la première fois un
ministre a autorité sur le cipdr qui
auparavant était interministériel et
donc n'avait pas me semble-t-il de
ministre de tutelle pour la première
fois me semble-t-il dans un décret
d'attribution c'est le cas et donc c'est
pour cette raison que c'est remonté au
niveau du cabinet pour des validations
mais ça ne veut pas dire que que le
cipdr est dépossédé de son pouvoir de
décision les éléments le démontrent
d'ailleurs on a effectivement des
nouvelles priorités politiques à cet
égard donc beaucoup sont concentrés au
cpdr la lutte contre les dérives
sectaires la montée en puissance des
ISCG qui sont gérés par le cipdr la
question de la lutte contre le cyber
islamisme qui nous préoccupe aujourd'hui
il y a un processus calé par le
directeur de cabinet l'administration
elle instruit et elle propose et
l'autorité ministérielle valide ce qui a
été instruit et proposé par
l'administration à mon humble avis c'est
un procédé classique il y a des réunions
qui existent avec le secrétaire général
et des réunions hebdomadaires entre le
LG cipdr
équivalent directeur d'administration et
le directeur de cabinet à ma
connaissance ce procédé est maintenu
d'ailleurs par ma successeur madame la
ministre bacaisse qui vous confirmera ou
pas enfin en tout cas s'exprimera sur ce
sujet tout à l'heure
oui donc
votre propos
confirme l'observation que j'ai
prononcé dans ma question
vous l'avez dit le pouvoir politique
c'est-à-dire le ministre
est où son directeur de cabinet on le
pouvoir de décider et de signer et
l'administration vous l'avez dit
d'ailleurs dans votre couple inductrice
introductif mettent en œuvre mais le
périmètre est en conforme à celui de
votre ministère et non plus sous
l'interministériel ça vous donne les
pleins pouvoirs de décision ça paraît de
ce côté là indiscutable monsieur le
rapporteur le ni le ministre ni le
cabinet ne signe d'attribution de
subventions parce que c'est la question
qui nous préoccupe aujourd'hui à aucun
moment ni le ministre ni le cabinet ne
met en paiement des crédits ou ne signe
de chaque c'est la prérogative de
l'administration et à aucun moment nous
n'avons ni la volonté ni même le pouvoir
matériel de le faire donc je suis claire
sur ce sujet je pense qu'on aura
l'occasion d'y revenir puisque il y a
manifestement des zones de conflits
entre les auditions et entre les
comment dirais les déclarations des uns
et des autres
à ce stade une dernière question vous
avez annoncé
le 31 mars 2021 la suppression de
l'Observatoire de la laïcité soit
quelques jours avant l'annonce le 20
avril de la création du fond Marianne et
à l'époque le gouvernement avait fait
l'objet de critique parfois assez vives
considérant qu'il était porteur d'une
vision très centralisée de la laïcité et
je cite évitant d'avoir une pluralité de
voix à l'intérieur de l'espace public
le fond Marianne s'inscrivait-il dans
dans cette logique visant à avoir un
message plutôt unique voire unitaire
autour et donc cohérent sur la laïcité
et notamment en prévoyant de
contractualiser avec des associations
s'inscrivant dans cette cohérence de la
parole
je vais assez unitaire du gouvernement
mais cela rapporteur s'agissant de
l'Observatoire de la laïcité l'annonce a
été faite par Monsieur le Premier
Ministre de l'époque à Monsieur le
Premier Ministre Jean Castex auprès de
qui l'Observatoire de la laïcité était
rattachée parce que c'est une
organisation qui dépendait de Matignon
qui est une organisation qui a produit
de nombreux rapports et qui a fait un
travail d'observation de la laïcité et y
compris de contributions au débat public
qui est un apport important qui je crois
n'a pas été contestée ou remis en cause
en tout cas dans la qualité des rapports
et du travail mené par cette
organisation
plurielle pour reprendre votre
expression c'est donc le premier
ministre qui annonce le fait que le
gouvernement met fin à l'Observatoire de
la laïcité non pas sur une question de
désaccord de ligne mais à ma
connaissance parce que nous entendons
passer à un autre mode d'action vous
aviez un observatoire qui donc observait
produisait des rapports ou des
recommandations et nous avons souhaité
avec Monsieur le Premier Ministre de
l'époque
créé non seulement un comité
interministériel à la laïcité qui soit
chargée de la réflexion et de
l'impulsion d'action concrète et de
politique publique portée par le
gouvernement sur la question de la
laïcité mais aussi d'un bureau de la
laïcité il n'y en avait pas précédemment
au ministère de l'Intérieur il y avait
un bureau déculte il n'y avait pas de
bureau de la laïcité et donc nous
l'avons créé afin de faire en sorte de
passer si vous permettez l'expression de
l'observation à l'action en la matière
et à la possibilité de coordonner les
actions menées en matière de laïcité
donc je vais redire parce que c'est ce
que je mettais noté vous choisissez
après avoir observé une manière
convergente à vous entendre à l'action
donc la capacité à agir et si j'ai bien
compris votre propos à l'instant tout à
fait dans l'esprit des travaux de
l'observatoire et donc
le même esprit fort de la volonté d'agir
au regard des événements
consécutifs à l'assassinat de Samuel
Paty
mais je ne crois absolument pas qu'il
n'y ait aucun acteur membre de
l'Observatoire de la laïcité qui
souhaite ne pas agir manque de
l'ancienne observatoire de la laïcité
qui souhaite ne pas agir face au
terrorisme je n'ai jamais dit cela et je
ne le crois pas
ne vous méprenez pas j'ai pas du tout
mis en doute je dis j'essaie simplement
on observe on agit il est mis fin un
observatoire je veux juste m'assurer
c'était le sens de ma question que la
volonté d'agir elle s'inscrit dans le
droit fil des travaux de l'observatoire
et du nouveau contexte c'est uniquement
le sens de ma question très sincèrement
est en sincèrement je peux pas me
prononcer sur l'intégralité des rapports
émis pendant des années par
l'Observatoire de la laïcité n'ayant les
ayons pas là sous les yeux avec moi
enfin il y a pas de
si si c'est bien la question mais je
suis pas sûr d'avoir compris votre
question mais si c'est la question en
tout cas
c'est la réponse
c'est donc ma réponse de toute façon
des des sujets que nous avons évoqué
mais un peu plus dans le dans le détail
pour valider ou pas les positions que
vous avez exprimé
alors je vais changer de registre et on
va venir directement sur sur le dossier
le sans doute le plus compliqué qui a
donné lieu d'ailleurs à un rapport
d'abord à part si je peux dire d'un
inspection générale de l'administration
en lui mettant en lumière un certain
nombre de difficultés et dans des termes
que je qualifierais d'extrêmement dur
et donc on va on va venir tout de suite
sur scène de points très très précis
donc premier point c'est les contacts
même monsieur Mohamed cifaoui avant mars
et puis j'allais dire avant votre entrée
en fonction puis après votre entrée en
fonction
donc dans quel contexte vous êtes connu
et quels ont été vos échanges et si vous
voulez bien le détailler justement avant
votre entrée en fonction s'il y en a eu
puis après votre en fonction et puis on
arrivera évidemment sur sur le début
des discussions sur le fond Marianne
bien entendu mais j'y reviendrai plus
précisément d'abord le contexte
concernant le contexte d'abord peut-être
de de l'association et puis ensuite de
Monsieur cifaoui si ça vous convient
d'abord sur la question de l'ucpm
j'observe que le rapport effectivement
de l'igéa qui est dur mais qui est
factuel me semble-t-il qui est documenté
par des je vous interrompre si vous
voulez
on viendra vers l'association après
parce que on a bien compris que
l'association elle arrivait dans un
deuxième temps
très proche d'ailleurs de la réponse au
fond Marianne donc dans un premier temps
ou avez-vous rencontré Monsieur Sifaoui
comment état de vos relations voilà je
vous remercie pour votre question
monsieur le Président qui va me
permettre je l'espère de clarifier un
certain nombre de choses je j'ai eu
l'occasion de le dire mais je le dis et
sous serment et dans ce contexte et face
à cette commission je ne suis pas une
amie de Monsieur Sifaoui et je le dis
parce que dans un premier temps c'est ce
qui a été rapporté et c'est ce qui a été
dit je le dément il est
difficile de démontrer qu'on n'est pas
ami avec quelqu'un si on dit je ne suis
pas amie et qu'en face on nous dit si
vous êtes amis monsieur CIFA oui
lui-même s'est exprimé sur BFM TV et a
dit également je ne suis pas un ami de
Madame Schiappa
le terme ami est un mot-valise alors
je vais éliminer les hypothèses une par
une monsieur le Président
qui est la laïcité voilà je vais
éliminer une par une monsieur le
Président si vous me le permettez toutes
ces hypothèses je ne suis pas une amie
de Monsieur Sifaoui je n'ai aucune
relation personnelle donc une sorte avec
Monsieur cifaoui et je n'en ai jamais eu
je ne suis pas avec Monsieur cifaoui
membre de même organisations nous ne
nous retrouvons pas dans tel ou tel
association ou organisation en dehors de
mon action ministérielle je n'ai pas
l'occasion de rencontrer Monsieur
cifaoui dans aucun lieu privé ni chez
lui ni chez moi ni dans une activité
sportive et je peux vous faire
l'intégralité de la liste je ne connais
pas sa vie personnelle ni sa famille il
connaît pas la mienne bref nous ne
sommes pas amis nous ne sommes pas dans
sans associés nous n'avons pas d'intérêt
commun et nous ne sommes ensemble
la connaissance membre d'aucune
organisation puisque c'est aussi le
sous-jacent de pas de vous monsieur le
Président mais de certaines formulations
qui ont été faites moi monsieur cifaoui
je le vois à plusieurs reprises et pas
en tête à tête et je tiens à le dire ici
parce que l'un des témoignages qui a été
apportés devant votre commission à
affirmer que j'aurais reçu
personnellement en tête-à-tête monsieur
Sifaoui au mois de mars et que ce serait
à cette occasion que je lui aurais
annoncé qu'il aurait une subvention ou
qu'il serait éligible au fond Marianne
c'est faux
c'est faux je tiens à le dire ici sous
serment c'est faux je le dis et c'est
documenté par l'ensemble de mon agenda
et des échanges de messages avec mon
cabinet j'ai un message d'un de mes
conseillers daté environ du 20 avril peu
ouprou qui d'ailleurs m'interpelle en me
disant que je n'ai pas rencontré
Monsieur Sifa oui de mémoire dans son
mail il dit vous devriez rencontrer
recevoir Monsieur cifaoui donc moi j'ai
participé à des événements ministériels
auxquels monsieur Sifaoui était présent
notamment et je l'ai lu dans la presse
ou dans un rapport ce que j'en avais pas
souvenir j'ai fait un déplacement dans
le Tarn et Monsieur Siffert
je crois à ma connaissance par le sgcpdr
pour délivrer une formation à cette
occasion nous ne sommes pas je n'ai pas
moi congé monsieur Sifaoui à venir
j'étais présente et il était présent il
est intervenu également il a également
participé à une visioconférence avec
d'autres experts
que je peux citer si vous le souhaitez
dans le cadre des travaux préparatoires
à la loi séparatiste puisqu'il était un
interlocuteur du cipdr monsieur cifaoui
était en lien avec le cpdr longtemps
avant ma propre nomination il y a des
comptes rendus qui sont dans les
dossiers qui montrent qu'il est reçu et
qu'il a des entretiens avec le cipdr ce
qui n'est pas anormal puisque c'est à ce
moment un acteur reconnu de l'écosystème
de la lutte contre l'islamisme il a
publié des ouvrages il fait des
interventions et donc il fait partie des
acteurs consultés par le cipdr mais je
tiens à être clair et formel sur le fait
que nous ne sommes pas amis nous n'avons
pas de relation personnelle et nous
n'avons pas d'intérêt commun ou
d'appartenance communes à ma
connaissance à tel ou tel organisation
j'espère avoir été clair monsieur le
Président la réponse est claire en tout
cas
monsieur
Sifaoui a affirmé alors c'est dans le
rapport de l'IGA puisque nous n'avons
pas vous le savez pu entendre
sincèrement monsieur cifaoui
malheureusement nous sommes décalés à
demain
mais monsieur Sifaoui selon le rapport
de l'IGA a affirmé qu'il y a eu 6
réunions entre lui et votre cabinet en
mars et avril 2021 et qu'il y a eu un
échange avec vous durant deux de ces
réunions et votre directeur de cabinet a
dit que c'était en fait qui est venu le
saluer cursivement donc
voilà donc vous nous direz
qu'elles ont pu être les échanges à ce
moment-là que vous avez eu avec Monsieur
cifaoui si vous le voulez bien et si
vous en souvenez avec précision et le
cas échéant bien sûr si cela est vrai je
parle des six rencontres c'est pas une
rencontre c'est pas de rencontre c'est 6
rencontres
quels étaient donc les réunions en
question et et sur quoi porter porter
les discussions
c'est un point extrêmement important
vous le comprenez
juste je remets dans
un peu dans la chronologie des faits
puisque nous sommes là avant avant même
l'appel d'offres Marianne
oui monsieur le Président d'abord sur
les rencontres et ce qui se dit entre
monsieur Sifaoui et mon cabinet ou
l'administration parce que je sais pas
si les six rencontrent ont lieu avec mon
cabinet et où l'administration j'ai lu
le chiffre de ces rencontres j'ai lu
d'ailleurs dans un journal a fait un
raccourci en disant que c'était si
rencontre avec moi-même j'espère qu'il
est clair aujourd'hui que ce n'est pas
le cas mais dans ces dans ces
discussions je ne sais pas monsieur le
Président je ne sais pas ce qui se dit
entre mon cabinet et Monsieur Sifa oui
je ne peux qu'imaginer qu'il parle de
lutte contre l'islamisme contre le cyber
islamiste que Monsieur Sifaoui peut-être
fait part des projets qui sont qui sont
les siens et en ce qui concerne les
moments où je vais le saluer moi j'ai
matériellement ça veut pas dire qu'il y
en a pas eu d'autres peut-être que je
suis allé le saluer et que je ne m'en
souviens pas on parle de fait il y a
quasiment deux ans mais Monsieur le
Préfet j'allais dit j'ai pas de raison
de ne pas le croire que je suis venue
saluer lors d'un rendez-vous du 22 avril
si ma mémoire est bonne monsieur Sifaoui
c'est tout à fait probable ça m'arrive
fréquemment de venir saluer de manière
par courtoisie les gens qui sont reçus
par les membres de mon cabinet je n'ai
pas souvenir monsieur le Président de ce
que j'ai pu lui dire très honnêtement au
moment de le saluer mais en tout cas si
c'est la question je ne lui ai pas dit
que j'allais lui attribuer une
subvention ou lui faire attribuer une
subvention ça je ne le fais jamais donc
c'est très clair ni même ni même
l'encourager à déposer un dossier dans
le cadre du fond Marianne alors ça très
honnêtement ce n'est pas impossible que
j'encourage des gens à déposer des
dossiers je le fais pardon monsieur le
Président mais tout le temps là je suis
aujourd'hui chargée de l'économie
sociale et solidaire dans les dernières
semaines j'ai reçu des gens qui m'ont
dit qu'ils souhaitaient pouvoir être
subventionnés et je leur ai dit je vous
encourage vivement à déposer un dossier
auprès de l'administration pour que
l'administration instruise votre dossier
et pardon de dévoiler cela mais
encourager quelqu'un à déposer un
dossier ça ne veut pas dire qu'on va le
soutenir c'est une formule générale qui
signifie aussi que on l'encourage
déposer le dossier et que le dossier
sera étudié et à renvoyer l'étude du
dossier à l'administration c'est en tout
cas comme ça que je conçois les choses
oui alors vous nous dites vous nous
dites il y a eu peut-être ces réunions
enfin en tout cas vous ne savez pas
voilà
avec votre cabinet nous dites ça vous
nous dites je ne sais pas ce qui s'est
dit entre mon cabinet je remets les mots
entre mon cabinet monsieur Sifaoui
c'est la question du fond Marianne est
sur la table maintenant depuis quelques
mois
vous avez pas interrogé votre directeur
de cabinet entre temps pour venir
préparer cette audition pour lui dire il
semblerait que vous ayez rencontré
si vous ne connaissez pas donc je sais
pas où il y a plusieurs reprises que ce
que vous avez pu dire etc nous je vous
rappelle que nous avons eu l'information
par le rapport de l'igéa c'est-à-dire
postérieurement à l'audition de Monsieur
j'allais sinon nous aurions directement
posé la question mais ce que je veux
vous dire c'est qu'il est difficile il
est difficile
d'imaginer qu'un ministre et son cabinet
ne fonctionne pas totalement en totale
totale comment dire confiance et en
totale transmission on connaît quand
même voilà on est bien les structures de
cabinet on connaît bien la manière de
travailler et je ne vois pas quand même
je peux pas imaginer un directeur de
cabinet ou un conseiller spécial de
votre cabinet changer de ces questions
avancer dans le cadre de 6 réunions si
elles ont eu lieu les 6 puisque pour
l'instant on a on n'a pas de
confirmation de votre part mais si elles
ont eu lieu ne pas avancer sans vous
faire un reporte un reporting tout
simplement
une note ou un propos oral mais en tout
cas sur des sujets de sa nature je
rappelle aussi madame pour bien aller au
fond de ma pensée que on est sur un
sujet sur lequel la communication votre
communication la communication du
ministère a été extrêmement forte sur un
sujet ça a été rappelé par le rapporteur
qui est encore dans tous les esprits
aujourd'hui je samedi exemple je vais
être à Toulouse à l'inauguration d'une
place ou d'une rue Samuel Paty
elle est dans tous les esprits donc si
vous voulez vous êtes sur un sujet qui
est sensible vous êtes sur une position
politique affichée et vous ne suivriez
pas
les discussions entre votre cabinet et
Monsieur Sifaoui par exemple
j'ai un peu de mal donc si vous voulez
bien revenir là-dessus
bien sûr monsieur le Président
d'abord sauf erreur de ma part ce n'est
pas Monsieur le Préfet Jallet donc
directeur de cabinet à ce moment là il
me semble qu'il reçoit monsieur Sifaoui
je pense mais à vérifier sauf élément
matériel contraire mais je pense qu'il
est reçu par
l'administration et par des membres de
mon cabinet et notamment je vous le
disais dans le cadre de la préparation
de la loi dit de séparatisme la loi pour
conforter les principes de la République
dans ce cadre
on est en avril 2021 on est déjà bien
après la réflexion préalable à la loi me
semble-t-il
rencontres elles n'ont pas lieu en avril
21 en fait quand on quand on relate le
fait que Monsieur Sifaoui a été reçu
avant le fond Marianne
mars et avril 2021 donc on n'est pas sur
la question de la loi ça c'était avant
qui a eu effectivement des visio avec
différents experts tout ça tout ça est
très clair alors c'est ça que je
mentionnais dans mon propos et c'est
pour ça que je j'éclairais le thème de
ces échanges à cet égard vous l'avez
très justement dit monsieur le Président
il y a une relation de confiance entre
un ministre et son cabinet et donc moi
en tout cas peut-être que c'est une
erreur mais en tout cas c'est comme ça
que je fonctionne je ne vais pas par
exemple regarder les agendas des membres
de mon cabinet et je ne leur demande pas
quotidiennement qu'ils ont reçu ou avec
qui ils ont échangé il y a des réunions
thématiques globales et c'est à cette
occasion que du cabinet font état des
personnes qui ont vu en revanche ce que
je peux vous dire
matériellement puisque j'en ai la trace
que j'ai retrouvé j'en avais aucun
souvenir mais je l'ai retrouvé dans mes
mails et vous aurez donc accès j'ai des
membres de mon cabinet qui reçoivent
monsieur cifaoui à une reprise lorsqu'il
présente un projet il dit qu'il a un
projet de contredours sur le cyber
islamisme et c'est à cette occasion que
mon cabinet m'adresse un mail c'est le
seul trace écrite que j'ai relatif un
rendez-vous entre des membres de mon
cabinet et Monsieur Sifaoui et dans ce
mail il m'explique ce projet c'est à ce
mail d'ailleurs que je réponds puisqu'il
me détaille les montants du projet et je
réponds pardon pour la familiarité mais
c'est un échange qui a évocation à ce
moment-là je réponds ceci 300ke d'argent
de l'État pour ce projet ça me paraît
énorme ici
c'est ma réponse et je me réjouis
aujourd'hui de l'avoir répondu par écrit
parce que ça démontre bien que j'ai
trouvé que ce projet était trop coûteux
on me demande mon premier avis mon
conseiller dans une discussion
informelle me parle d'un projet ma
première réponse et mon impulsion c'est
de dire c'est trop cher et donc ensuite
s'ensuivre des échanges par écrit donc
ils sont documentés que IgA a eu et que
vous aurez également vous avez peut-être
déjà d'ailleurs dans lesquels on discute
de ce projet des membres de mon cabinet
soutenant le projet et le détaillant et
le directeur de cabinet rappelant qu'il
y a une procédure qu'elle existe
rappelant par écrit les étapes de cette
procédure et invitant à ne pas débattre
de cette sorte mais à intégrer ce projet
dans le cadre du comité de sélection en
tout cas de la procédure qui existe
je sais pas si ça répond à votre
question partiellement madame
partiellement
à deux reprises vous savez
la question elle est quand même très
simple
quand il y a une position d'un cabinet
notamment écrite elle engage son
ministre on est bien d'accord bon il y a
une responsabilité conjointe voilà ce
qui me permet de vous dire d'ailleurs
tout de suite madame la ministre que
dans votre propos introductif il y a
quelques moments que ce soit jusqu'à
présent vous devez mis en cause votre ou
en jeu ou en discussion votre propre
responsabilité pour l'instant vous dites
c'est l'administration c'est le cabinet
voilà
non madame
quand le cabinet prend une position elle
est supposée être la position de la
ministre ou du ministre je veux dire de
manière faut pas voilà de manière
générale c'est comme ça que les choses
se font et heureusement parce que sinon
quel serait la qualité d'une
intervention du cabinet si ce n'était
pas la voix de du ministre voilà et donc
et donc ça me paraît très important de
revenir dessus alors
on a plusieurs plusieurs échanges on y
reviendra tout à l'heure sur plusieurs
plusieurs sociétés plusieurs
associations pardon mais
entre le 9 et le 13 avril par exemple
votre conseiller spécial interroge le
cpdr sur la bonne réception de la
demande de Monsieur sefaoui c'est-à-dire
que
on va plus loin tout à l'heure on
rappellera mais vous connaissez cette
phrase du préfet Gravel qui
qui évidemment je vous la donne tout de
suite faut pas je la rappelle à tout le
monde
c'est cifaoui indique je n'ai pas pris
cette alors sur Twitter je prends encore
une fois pas devant notre voilà je le
prends avec précaution je n'ai pas pris
cette initiative spontanément j'y étais
encouragé par des représentants des
pouvoirs publics notamment par les
membres du cabinet madame Schiappa et
par elle-même donc à l'occasion sans
doute de ce petit contact furtif vous
nous dites que il vous arrive
régulièrement d'encourager bon
je suis donc quelque peu scandalisés en
constatant que les participes gentiment
au lynchage
bon ce sont ça c'est important ce sont
les membres du cabinet Marlène Schiappa
qui ont insisté pour que je prenne part
à la riposte citoyenne
on peut imaginer les choses finalement
des gens qui sont sur ce terrain là
on est on l'a souvent dit dans ces
auditions sur comment dire un petit
nombre d'acteurs en tout état de cause
bon donc mais tout de même une chose et
comment dire d'avoir un contact une
autre est
d'encourager je reprends les termes
les membres du cabinet ont insisté pour
que je prenne part à la riposte
citoyenne
et puis on a des échanges derrière de
votre cabinet vers le secrétariat
général pour finalement avoir des
informations pour savoir si
la le dossier de candidature est bien
arrivé si on peut l'intégrer ça va très
loin c'est à dire que
le directeur de cabinet de Madame bac S
nous a fait une démonstration que je
trouve assez juste et assez classique
c'est-à-dire qu'un ministre un cabinet
est souvent comment dire reçoit souvent
des demandes et sollicités c'est évident
et
lorsqu'il est sollicité
il la tradition la méthode
l'organisation veut que le cabinet ou le
ministre transmettent à son
administration pour analyse le dossier
présenté voilà et ce garde bien jusqu'à
comment dire à ce que le dossier soit
face l'objet d'un rapport par
l'administration se garde bien
d'intervenir dans le sujet là on est sur
quelque chose de très différent on est
sur quelque chose de très différent
parce que il y aurait eu donc une
sollicitation on vous demande de votre
avis vous pouvez pas nous répondre je
sais pas ce que le cabinet a fait s'il a
appelé monsieur Sifaoui s'il ne l'a pas
appelé si c'est Monsieur Sifaoui de
notre autorité est venue connaissant
mais c'est pas ce que ça nous dit ce que
nous disent les auditions ce que nous
disent les auditions c'est que d'une
alors l'hygia d'une part je viens de le
dire et les auditions monsieur Gravel
nous dit que il a reçu un coup de fil de
monsieur cifaoui lui indiquant que on
n'est pas du tout dans la transmission
par le cabinet à l'administration on est
sur quelque chose de totalement
différent madame la ministre peut-être
le rapporteur
oui madame vous pouvez répondre à ce
point
madame la ministre
je crois avoir posé les questions je
vous prie mais je pensais que vous aviez
une aparté excusez-moi j'ai mal j'ai mal
interprété votre
regard
pardon monsieur le Président bien sûr je
vous réponds d'abord en ce qui concerne
ma responsabilité je me défonce pas je
ne des repas je suis là devant vous et
j'entends endosser ma responsabilité
toute ma responsabilité pardon pour la
formulation mais aussi rien que ma
responsabilité que le ministre soit
comptable et soit
rendent des comptes et soirée
responsables devant le Parlement de
l'action menée non seulement par
lui-même mais aussi par son cabinet bien
évidemment et son administration
politiquement c'est c'est bien
évidemment normal et c'est pourquoi bien
évidemment je suis là autant que de
besoin maintenant et dans l'avenir si
vous avez besoin de complément
d'information ou autre donc j'ai
toujours en toute circonstances pris à
mes responsabilités j'ai énormément de
défauts certainement pas celui de me
dérober donc je suis là et bien sûr je
vous réponds dans toute ma
responsabilité et dans rien que ma
responsabilité moi je n'ai aucune et de
même que le mot coupable n'a pas été
prononcé par cette mission
le mot coupable nous on parle pas de
culpabilité on parle de
responsabilités
à ma connaissance moi je ne suis accusé
de rien donc bien évidemment ce n'est
pas le sujet je suis là pour vous aider
à établir des faits la matérialité des
faits au dehors des commentaires des uns
et des autres et la chronologie des
faits donc c'est bien là-dessus que
j'irai et d'ailleurs je je n'ai pas non
plus à
préjugé de culpabilité de quel acteur
que ce soit puisqu'il y a une
instruction judiciaire en cours qui les
concerne qui ne me concerne pas et donc
et donc ce concerne pas non plus bien
sûr bien évidemment donc tout ça pour
dire que cabinet a fait confiance à un
acteur qui à ce moment là un acteur
reconnu de ce sujet qui est monsieur
cifaoui qui est à ce moment là déjà
soutenu par le cipdr il y a des
rencontres qui sont documentées il y a
un site de monsieur cifaoui qui
s'appelle islamoscope qui est référencé
comme partenaire du cipdr et donc il y a
vraiment cette antériorité moi je veux
être très clair sur le fait puisque je
réponds pour ce que j'ai fait je n'ai
pas connaissance d'autres échanges
personnels mais l'ija et vous même et
peut-être la justice le diront mais moi
je suis formelle je vous le dis
sincèrement je n'ai à aucun moment
demandé ou passer commande à ce que
Monsieur Sifaoui soit priorisé ou mis au
dessus de la pile je n'avais aucune
raison de le faire et je ne l'ai pas
fait d'ailleurs le rapport de l'igéa est
très clair sur ma responsabilité dans le
cadre du processus de sélection
puisqu'il établit qu'après avoir
impuissé cette politique publique il dit
la ministre c'est effacer du processus
de sélection c'est la conclusion écrite
dans le rapport de l'igéa
de vous reprendre le rapport ne dit pas
ça
il y a juste avant la petite phrase qui
est selon les auditions menées
la ministre je parle n'a pas participé
cette tenue à l'écart mais il y a bien
avant la petite phrase selon les
personnes auditées
et puis d'autre part et puis d'autre
part l'inspection générale de
l'administration son rôle c'est de
contrôler l'administration elle est pas
là pour porter un jugement de
responsabilité politique en aucune façon
il ne l'a jamais fait je jeudi et je
vous me demandez ma parole donc je vous
donne ma parole et sous serment je vous
dis que je n'ai à aucun moment ni
prioriser moi-même ni demander de
prioriser le dossier de Monsieur cifaoui
et j'ajoute que je n'avais aucune raison
de demander à prioriser le dossier de
Monsieur Sifaoui et que je ne l'ai pas
fait j'ajoute aux deux grands que ce
dossier était soutenu par
l'administration par le cpdr puisque
manifestement il a été
donné un avis favorable au fait de
pouvoir financer ce dossier de manière
unanime par l'ensemble des membres du
comité de sélection c'est-à-dire tant
les membres du cabinet que les membres
de l'administration c'est en tout cas
les éléments dont moi je dispose
monsieur le Président en même temps
madame la ministre vous savez comment
les choses se passent c'est à dire que
lorsqu'on cabinet demande à
l'administration
de regarder de près un dossier se
réinterroge sur est-ce qu'il a bien été
déposé
participe à des discussions on y viendra
plus tard sur le montant à louer
bon l'administration a quand même du mal
quoi qu'on pense monsieur Gravel qui par
ailleurs a dit plutôt du bien de
Monsieur Sifaoui dans son audition qui
est plutôt dans le sens d'un accord mais
quoi qu'il en soit la lorsqu'une demande
Vienne donc cabinet et donc de la
ministre de manière peut-être
involontaire c'est ce que vous nous
dites mais en fait quand le cabinet
parle à son administration on a toujours
la ministre ou le ministre derrière
quand on est dans l'administration et
donc on arrive à un accord cela ne nous
choque pas ce cas ce qui est important
et on y reviendra c'est la façon dont ça
donc ça c'est dans Ça c'est monté
c'est le rapporteur
chronologie des faits parce que j'ai
toujours à ce stade quelques difficultés
à m'y retrouver vous n'avez pas être
matérialité de chronologie moi je suis
assez basique
de ce côté là parce que
le calendrier il est ce qu'il est donc
vous nous avez tout à l'heure d'ailleurs
évoqué un mail du 20 avril je vais juste
vous me permettre de vous corriger
puisque
ce qui a été
ce qui nous a été transmis c'est un mail
du 6 avril 2001 et non pas du vin donc
adressé à votre cabinet qui
effectivement indiqué le montant de
300000 euros qualifié d'énormes
mais le 9 avril
donc trois jours après
lui seppm envoie tout de même une
demande de subvention de
635000 euros qui sera réduite à 300.000
euros le 13 avril
2021 lors du comité de programmation je
rappelle qu'à ce stade le fond Marianne
n'est pas créé
à ce stade est-ce qu'on doit en déduire
que la décision d'octroyer les 300.000
euros à l'USSE ppm avait finalement été
non seulement envisagé mais je dirais
acté par vos équipes et par votre
cabinet en amont même du comité de
programmation dont je rappelle qu'il
s'est tenu le 13 avril et donc avant
même le dépôt officiel de la demande de
subvention
monsieur le rapporteur moi je tiens à
vous dire que mon point de vue sur ce
montant n'a changé à aucun moment vous
avez bien compris c'est pas la question
la question maintenant c'est la
procédure les montants et la séquence
dans laquelle
le la subvention est déjà prêt accordée
mais c'est le regard qu'on porte sur un
montant qui procède à un arbitrage ou à
un non arbitrage
point de vue je l'ai donné à mon cabinet
par écrit et j'ai dit que pour moi
300.000 euros c'était une somme énorme
de surcroît si l'État était le seul
financeur c'est pourquoi à ma
connaissance
rétrospectivement aujourd'hui quand je
recoupe les éléments il aurait été
demandé à Monsieur Sifaoui de trouver
des co-financement d'après ce que j'ai
compris
je vous demande simplement de confirmer
je vous ai donné le séquençage entre le
6 et le 13 avril des montants est-ce
qu'ils sont conformes ou est-ce que je
commets une erreur et c'est la manière
de procéder et donc est-ce que c'était
finalement une subvention fléchée avant
même le fond Marianne je ne peux pas
vous dire Monsieur le Rapporteur ce qui
a procédé au changement de montant dans
la demande
je vais revenir
c'est une question importante parce que
tout simplement elle montre ou pas
en accord avec vous alors un accord avec
vous
sous la réserve que vous dites c'est
énorme ici et il vous répondent que
répondre techniquement que ces jouables
que s'il y a du que ça a du sens qui est
ce qui ne va pas et finalement ce qui
fait dire à l'IGA et c'est très
important que c'est des ni transparents
ni équitables c'est que des associations
ont finalement fait l'objet d'arbitrage
par votre cabinet
préalablement à toute demande et à tout
dépôt de dossiers et ça c'est
excusez-moi de vous le dire c'est votre
mail même
que vous nous avez transmis pour comment
dire exprimer votre position sur les 300
000 qui dit ça qui dit que vous avez par
arbitré mais était questionné par votre
cabinet sur 300.000 euros avant même
tout dossier ce qui veut dire tout
simplement que effectivement dès le
départ cette procédure fait qu'il y a
plusieurs types d'associations et qui a
des associés en particulier qui sont
réglés avant en tout cas pour celle là
les faits sont établis
est-ce que vous contestez c'est fait
moi monsieur le Président Monsieur le
rapporteur je n'ai d'abord dans les
mails c'est à vérifier mais il me semble
beaucoup très caution mais il me semble
que le mail de mon conseiller ne fait
pas référence je crois au fond Marianne
mais qui fait référence
ne mélangez pas je vous ai donné une
matérialité une séquence je vous demande
juste est-ce que vous contestez les
éléments que je vous ai présenté
que la question est la question est
claire soit des versements qui ont été
fléchés par avance vous le dites et
ça clarifie les choses moi monsieur le
rapporteur je n'ai moi je suis comme
vous matérialité et chronologie et
matériellement je n'ai pas de fait qui
viennent dire que le cabinet donne un
ordre
de versement de cette subvention
d'abord le versement celui-ci PDR c'est
l'administration qui verse non il s'agit
c'est un bref fléchage sur un montant de
300000 qui d'ailleurs comme par hasard
devient finalement la proposition du
cpdr au moment du comité voilà c'est
tout simple je regarde monsieur le
Président ce que ce que ce dont je
dispose comme fait pour ces discussions
qui ont eu lieu il y a deux ans et donc
je me suis à ce dont je dispose ce dont
je dispose c'est qu'effectivement
manifestement les membres de mon cabinet
tout comme le cipdr était en soutien de
l'initiative portée par Monsieur cifaoui
leur mail démontre qu'ils ont un
enthousiasme vis-à-vis du projet de
Monsieur Sifaoui ça ne moi je n'ai pas
d'éléments qui vise à dire que le
cabinet aurait à ce moment-là arbitrer
ou décider quelque chose avant le comité
de sélection et je tiens à rappeler par
quelle porte d'entrée arrive monsieur
Sifaoui c'est par le SV c'est considère
avec lequel il travaillait ou
l'entretenait des relations précédemment
et l'autre le cabinet et le cpdr
travailler avec enthousiasme et
finalement que vous validez la
enthousiasme dans un même j'interprète
enthousiasme je n'ai pas d'éléments
matériels
que vous n'avez pas contesté la mère
terrialité des séquences ce qui
finalement est pour moi un élément de
réponse c'est un élément de réponse qui
nous permettra madame la ministre
ensuite de rendre nos conclusions voilà
je ne fais pas de je ne tire pas
d'enseignement particulier j'avais
simplement besoin au titre de la
Commission de vérifier le déroulement et
la chronologie des faits et si vous me
permettez puisque il y a une réserve
savoir pour quelle raison au final il a
été décidé d'attribuer ces 300.000 euros
à l'USSE ppm
pourquoi ensuite d'ailleurs elle a
déposé une demande de d'un projet à
355000 euros dans le fond Marianne les
50-6000 euros supplémentaires
est-ce que c'est une
idée géniale et ce qui a eu un échange
avec le cipdr votre cabinet voire
vous-même au cours d'échanges dit furtif
voilà moi je j'ai simplement aussi
besoin de savoir quel est le rôle que
chacun a pu tenir ce qui n'a rien enfin
je veux aussi vous mettre parfaitement à
l'aise de répréhensible nous avons juste
besoin de comprendre et de faire la
lumière voilà au titre de la mission de
contrôle de l'action du gouvernement et
de la dépense publique qui plus est avec
des associations et comme l'a dit à nos
collègues parfois dans nos collectivités
pour 1000 euros il faut montrer patte
blanche et avoir un dossier très carré
je souscris parfaitement à vos propos
je me permets simplement de dire que je
n'ai pas dans mes réponses ni confirmer
ni infirmer cette chronologie enfin
j'insiste parce que c'est quelque soit
le niveau d'importance de cette je ne
sais pas
je ne sais pas je ne suis pas en mesure
de vous je ne connais pas les échanges
qui ont pu avoir lieu sur ce sujet tout
ce que je sais est matériellement ce que
je sais c'est que le comité de sélection
est unanime sur le soutien qu'il faut
apporter à Monsieur CIFA oui je ne me
mêle pas du montant on m'indique que le
comité de sélection à part cette
remarque où je dis que en amont que je
trouve que c'était énorme le comité de
sélection propose un montant se met
d'accord sur un bénéficiaire qui est
l'association dans laquelle les monsieur
Sifaoui et se met d'accord sur ce
montant et moi je ne BIF pas ce montant
ni dans un sens ni dans l'autre je ne
donne pas d'avis sur ce montant
insuffisant
le constat on y reviendra plus tard vous
ne l'invalidez pas
contrairement à la liste finale
dans la liste fin
ale qu'il y a des noms et des montants
et je ne je n'ai pas de modification à
apporter et je veux dire que et pourquoi
je ne le sais pas c'est pas un
désintérêt de ma part je reviens à ce
que je disais c'est à dire que on peut
le déplorer on peut on peut estimer que
j'aurais dû le faire mais en tout cas je
ne suis pas mêlée d'une générique je
suis pas directeur d'administration ou
préfet ou chargé de mission et ne
revient pas l'attribution dossier par
dossier de chaque de chaque subvention
on ne m'a pas sollicité d'arbitrage
infini puisqu'il y avait un consensus et
donc ça a été ça a été engagé de la
sorte sur ce dossier là on va y revenir
madame madame la ministre envahir mais
quand on vous a juste dit la chronologie
en réalité la chronologie c'est vous qui
l'a donné donc elle est pas fausse par
nature
vous l'avez donné vous nous avez
transmis un mail du 6 du 6 avril
c'est-à-dire antérieur au dépôt du
dossier qui est une autre date
clarifiée qui est le 9 avril et donc le
6 avril votre cabinet arbitre sur un
montant de 300.000 euros qui comme par
hasard
devient le montant qui est présenté en
comité en comité qui suit voilà ça c'est
la chronologie que vous avez donné donc
votre mail il est juste enfin je veux
dire la date est juste à partir de là
tout le reste est un briquet voilà
je vais je vais vous proposer une petite
pause avec les questions mais pas totale
les questions de nos collègues de la
commission donc dans l'ordre j'ai Roger
carochi puis Vincent et blé quelques
autres
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Rapporteur madame la ministre certains
ici ont une expérience ministérielle et
savent très bien qu'effectivement on ne
demande pas ces membres du cabinet de
faire rapport sur tout on ne vérifie pas
leurs agendas heureusement ni qui
reçoivent et heureusement on aurait des
problèmes en sens inverse mais dans
cette affaire
qui qui est aujourd'hui l'objet de la
commission d'enquête il y a un élément
un peu
non pas gênant mais un peu curieux vous
dites vous-même madame la ministre et je
veux bien vous croire que bon il y avait
un comité de sélection vous n'avez pas
intervenir sur le montant de des
ensembles vous n'avez pas d'ailleurs à
faire le choix c'est au comité de
sélection de le faire mais alors dans
ces conditions pourquoi votre cabinet
vous interpelle sur la somme qui serait
attribuée à Monsieur
avant le comité de sélection et vous
répondez vous même c'est très bien de
l'avoir fait la somme me paraît énorme
ici parce que ça semble indiquer madame
la ministre qu'en réalité ce qui est
probable votre directeur de cabinet a
peut-être fait une présélection avant le
comité qu'on vous les a soumis quelques
idées ou en tout cas quelques montants
et que vous avez réagi au moins sur le
plus important celui de Monsieur Sifaoui
d'ailleurs quand vous dites vous-même
monsieur cifaoui et son association
plutôt demander où avait un projet à
600.000 euros vous avez vous dites vous
le dites vous-même vous avez proposé à
l'association enfin vous votre cabinet
avait proposé à l'association de trouver
des financements complémentaires
ailleurs ce qui revient à dire que avant
même que le comité de sélection des
projets se réunissent décide
le projet de Monsieur cifaoui avait été
plus ou moins validé par votre cabinet
qu'on avait compris que ça coûterait
plus cher que 300.000 euros qu'on lui
avait proposé de trouver des
financesment privés parallèles et donc
on a un peu le sentiment que sans que
vous soyez forcément vous-même
totalement impliqué mais qu'en réalité
avant le comité de sélection
le cabinet avait pris le pas sur
l'administration pour décider
merci madame la ministre si vous voulez
bien vous prenez trois les quelques
questions qu'il y a on va s'en tenir
assis question d'inscrits les autres
viendront dans un deuxième temps donc
Vincent et Blais puis Victorin Lurel
rapidement bien sûr merci monsieur le
Président donc sénateur de la
Seine-et-Marne madame la ministre je
voudrais
vous interroger sur
le subventionnement d'une association
dont il n'a pas encore été beaucoup fait
état dans nos discussions d'aujourd'hui
qui est l'association reconstruire le
commun comme vous le savez sans doute
cette association a été constituée
seulement quelques semaines avant de
bénéficier des subventions d'État ce qui
est une chose qui personnellement m'a
beaucoup surpris car comme le rapporteur
général Husson
il faisait allusion tout à l'heure dans
les collectivités territoriales j'ai
présidé pour ma part une collectivité
importante quel conseil départemental de
Seine-et-Marne durant 11 années jamais
en 11 années nous n'avons subventionné
une association qui venait d'être
constituée tout simplement parce que
dans les conditions que nous émettons
pour subventionner une association
fusent de quelques centaines d'euros
alors a fortiori pour plus de 300000
nous demandons à disposer au moins des
comptes arrêtés d'un exercice entier
annuel de l'association et donc en ne
subventionne qu'à partir d'une année
complète d'existence c'est une
précaution je dirais qui me paraît
j'irai relativement normal donc je
voudrais vous demander si vous aviez
connaissance lorsque vous avez validé
l'ensemble des subventions accordées
dans le cadre de cet appel à projet si
vous aviez j'irai conscience que cette
association était de création récente ou
est-ce que vous l'ignoriez absolument et
est-ce que
[Musique]
qui semble-t-il n'existe pas est-ce
qu'il a fait l'objet de discussion avec
vos collaborateurs au sein du cabinet
avec les administrations en question ou
est-ce que et si c'est le cas est-ce que
il a été
sciemment
[Musique]
décidé que et bien ça n'était pas grave
de subventionner une association
débutante
et que j'irai
l'évolution assez rapide des questions
auxquelles le fond Marianne est destiné
à répondre j'irai pouvais justifier en
quelque sorte de retenir une jeune
association ou bien est-ce que tout ça
est en dehors de votre visibilité de
ministre je dirais en dehors des radars
merci merci Vincent madame la ministre
cette deuxième question vous la gardez
parce que le sujet qui est sur
reconstruire le commun va arriver
derrière et on l'a voilà et on
vous allez prendre les autres questions
alors la première vous pourrez répondre
la deuxième vous la gardez en mémoire
mais c'est quand on se rend sur le la
deuxième association un peu plus tard je
demande à chacun de bien vouloir
intervenir dans le champ de ce qui a été
déjà présenté parce que notre
notre audition va durer un petit peu et
nous avons d'autres thèmes Victorin
l'URL on est bien sur la matière j'en
suis pas sûr monsieur le Président
puisque j'avais l'intention n'interroger
la ministre sur
l'US ppm qui est une association
union de société
d'éducation physique et de préparation
militaire
le DL l'Observatoire de la laïcité a été
dissous et vous avez donc créé le fond
Marianne pour développer pour lutter
contre le séparatisme et donc développer
un contre discours républicain
j'aimerais savoir
quel est votre vision de ce contre
discours républicain qu'est-ce qu'on
reprochait à la laïcité qui n'était pas
apparemment suffisante pour passer à une
préparation militaire et peut-être
paramilitaire
c'est bien ça le nom de l'association
c'est une vieille association endormie
qui s'est réveillée et qui reçoit des
subventions quel était votre vision de
ce
discours contre républicain
quels étaient les liens avec
certains essayistes quel était votre
inspiration
quelle était la teneur de ce discours là
avait vu des liens également avec le
printemps républicain
est-ce que vous pourriez m'expliquer ça
merci
Vincent Segouin
oui merci monsieur le Président Madame
le Ministre monsieur Gravel a déclaré
qu'il a appris que Lulu l'use ppm
pourrait bénéficier des fonds Mariannes
lors d'un appel téléphonique de Mohamed
seifaoui il me dit sortir d'un
rendez-vous avec la ministre et nous
sommes en mars 2021 qu'en est-il est-ce
que c'est vrai
merci
Daniel broyier
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre la question que je voudrais
vous poser c'est pour mettre en place ce
contre discours républicain avez-vous
demandé à votre cabinet à
l'administration de chercher des acteurs
ou de chercher des associations dans
l'action était déjà visibles et réputée
parce qu'il y a pour moi une
interrogation vous dites je n'avais
aucune raison d'appuyer monsieur cifaoui
aviez-vous des raisons inverses de ne
pas l'appuyer et comment se fait-il que
l'administration semble dialoguer avec
un acteur avant de dialoguer avec une
association c'est pour moi une
interrogation il me semblait que on
allait chercher dans le les associations
déjà engagées dans cette action plutôt
que de cibler des acteurs donc vous
liez-vous qu'il y ait des acteurs où
vous vouliez vous qu'on aille chercher
l'ensemble des associations qui
intervenaient dans le champ de la
défense des valeurs de la République
merci Daniel Christian BIAC
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre
il y a quelques années j'étais à
l'association des vers de France nous
avions créé un groupe de travail qui
avait produit un valet bekoum sur la
laïcité et à cette occasion nous l'avons
auditionné beaucoup de ces acteurs de
terrain que vous avez cité et qui font
un travail remarquable la défaite de
laïcité et de la valeur de la République
il s'agit pour beaucoup d'entre eux de
coach sportifs qui travaillent auprès
des jeunes de club sportifs
essentiellement de football ou de boxe
qui font le travail remarquable et moi
la question que je vous pose quelle
notation ont obtenu chez clubs qui sont
déjà impliqués qui travaillent déjà dans
les quartiers quand une existence
reconnue ça rejoint un peu la question
de mon collègue voyez et je n'ai pas
souvenance par contre d'avoir des
journées le FPPM
comme acteur de terrain et comment
expliquer ces 300000 euros pour conclure
très rapidement je voudrais quand même
dire que moi je crois que ce fond malade
était une très bonne idée au départ
c'était une très bonne idée parce que
nous avons besoin de défendre la
République et ses valeurs et que je
n'aurais je ne ferais pas content je
suis à la fin de cette procédure ont
jeté je peux me permettre d'expression
peu populaire le bébé avait voulu du
bain et que si on fasse plaisir au
salafiste de tout poil et à ceux qui les
soutiennent
merci pour non pas cette question mais
ce commentaire Gérard Longuet
oui monsieur le Président c'est
exactement les mêmes observation que mon
prédécesseur madame la ministre vous
avez été en charge d'une responsabilité
extraordinairement lourde et nouvelle
c'est de bâtir un Dédé à bâtir un
discours pour défendre la laïcité
républicaine vis-à-vis de population qui
ont à l'égard de la religion n'ont pas
le même historique que la plupart de nos
compatriotes avez-vous rédiger un
document de base une charte de base de
en fait une la volonté politique et la
définition de votre projet politique
vous êtes complètement dans votre
responsabilité vous êtes en charge d'un
sujet majeur votre équipe va le mettre
en oeuvre va mobiliser un fond qui est
préexistant mais qui a un objectif très
différent la lutte contre la délinquance
tu as tout à fait raison le délinquance
de du quartier l'Association Sportive
foot c'est très bien mais là on parle de
quelque chose de très différent c'est un
message avec un cordes doctrine et ce
qu'on reprochait justement
l'Observatoire de la laïcité c'est de ne
pas avoir de cordes doctrine de ne pas
avoir de limites et de ne pas avoir de
règles de comportement donc avez-vous
bâti avez-vous l'occasion à vous le
temps tout simplement et la possibilité
de bâtir ce corps de doctrine avant de
de recruter des porte-paroles
nous poursuivrons les questions après la
deuxième séquence si vous le voulez bien
pour avancer et aussi pour permettre
dans la ministre faire la synthèse des
six premières questions qu'elle avait
bien répondre
bien sûr monsieur le Président je vous
remercie
d'abord
alors d'abord je me permets de revenir
je suis très brièvement sur votre
dernier propos conclusif disant que dans
la chronologie le cabinet avait arbitré
par mail les montants etc et pardon
risque de me répéter mais je n'ai pas
dans les échanges de mails d'arbitrage
du cabinet je tiens à le dire pour pas
qu'il soit retenu que j'aurais
implicitement validé cela dans les
échanges de mails il y a des discussions
on peut voir les positions et les points
de vue des uns et les autres mais il n'y
a pas d'arbitrage écrit en tout cas
matériellement je me permets de le dire
monsieur le ministre karucci pour
répondre à votre à vos différentes
questions vous faites référence aux
échanges de mails notamment que j'ai eu
avec mon cabinet en observant qu'ils
sont antérieurs au fond Marianne c'est
tout à fait juste et c'est d'ailleurs
pour cette raison que dans ces échanges
de mails ne figure pas de mention au
fond Marianne à ce moment là je ne dis
pas que ça ne veut pas dire que les
échanges ne soient pas intéressant au
regard de l'enquête qui est en train de
d'être mener ou de l'instruction qui est
en train d'être menée mais en tout cas
on n'est pas en train d'arbitrer des
subventions du fond Marianne du tout on
est en train justement d'avoir ce
compte-rendu thématique d'un membre de
mon cabinet sur un rendez-vous c'est
moi-même qui est souhaité porter ce mail
à la connaissance de la commission
d'enquête et le donner spontanément
d'initiatives parce que j'ai trouvé
justement qu'il éclairait ses débats là
et d'ailleurs dans ces messages on voit
que les membres du cabinet se répondent
et me répondent le directeur de cabinet
met fin à l'échange par la nature de sa
réponse puisque le directeur de cabinet
rappelle que pour toute attribuer son
subventions il y a une procédure et que
donc l'échange s'arrête là et reporter à
l'échange au moment des procédures
afférentes et il propose d'ailleurs à ce
moment-là un process pour ce qui est pas
encore le fond Marianne mais ce qui est
l'activité de entre guillemets contre
discours républicain il rappelle c'est
un long mail mais je pense que chacun là
dans le il rappelle le process qu'il
propose avec une validation
ministérielle infinie mais avec une
sélection une instruction des dossiers
par l'administration donc c'est
véritablement cette procédure qu'il
vient détailler dans ce mail là ça me
semble important et ça me semble
important aussi parce qu'on parlait des
de la chaîne de hiérarchie finalement et
des responsabilités de chacun et le
directeur de cabinet a préféré
parfaitement dans son rôle en disant il
y a une procédure donc on en discute pas
comme ça par message c'est le
sous-entendu il écrit pas comme ça mais
c'est le sous-entendu de son mail quand
il renvoie au comité de sélection
monsieur le sénateur LB sur la question
de la date de création de reconstruire
le commun c'est vrai que l'objet du feu
on la garde pour la suite quand on
parlera
voilà rembobiner je n'ai pas répondu à
monsieur le sénateur LB là-dessus tout à
l'heure bien sûr absolument monsieur le
sénateur l'URL vous avez parlé de
discours contre républicain il y a pas
de discours contre républicain je sais
pas si c'est oui ah d'accord est-ce que
vous avez dit le discours contre
républicain c'est un lapsus donc je
tiens à être clair sur ce sujet et
j'admets parce que j'ai entendu certains
débats que cette appellation n'est
peut-être pas la plus limpide qui soit
avec d'ailleurs on peut politiquement
mais c'est un autre sujet ça interroger
sur le non qu'on donne à ce discours
puisque nous qu'est-ce que nous mettons
dedans et nous mettons dedans le fait de
répondre à tout discours dit séparatiste
qui peut exister et donc de répondre
essentiellement à ce qu'on appelle le
terreau du terrorisme et donc au
discours de radicalisation et
d'islamisme mais plus largement au
discours qui peuvent attenter aux
institutions à la République et l'idée
c'est justement d'aider les jeunes
notamment qui sont sur ces réseaux
sociaux à se faire un propre avis à
exercer leur libre arbitre et à entendre
différentes positions sur ce sujet je
souhaiterais répondre à votre question
sur le printemps républicain et je vous
remercie de la poser parce que ça va me
permettre de clarifier un certain nombre
de choses d'abord
je ne dis rien contre le printemps
républicain mais je ne suis pas membre
du printemps républicain je tiens à le
dire ici parce que dans les
sous-entendus qui ont été non pas dans
cette commission d'enquête bien sûr mais
dans les commentaires qui en ont été
faits on entend un peu tout et n'importe
quoi et on attribue des amis à tort et
on attribue des appartenances à tort pas
plus que je ne suis pas ami avec
Monsieur Sifaoui je n'ai rien contre lui
mais pas de relation personnelle je n'ai
rien contre le printemps républicain
mais je ne suis pas membre du printemps
républicain vous avez des images des
reportages des photos d'événements de
lancement de jeu printemps républicain
jaune n'y figure pas et pourquoi je n'y
suis pas je n'en suis pas membre je
pourrais honnêtement c'est pas interdit
mais il s'avère que je ne le suis pas et
il s'avère également que le printemps
républicain n'a pas été associée à la
constitution du fond Marianne à aucun
moment en tout cas pas à ma connaissance
et pas par moi à aucun moment je ne vais
voir le printemps républicain dans le
cadre du fond Marianne et d'ailleurs
eux-mêmes ont souhaité faire un
communiqué pour dire qu'il n'avait pas
été associé donc une manière
je vais vous demander malheureusement
c'est l'exercice nous avons énormément
de questions à vous poser vous avez
intérêt d'ailleurs vous-même à répondre
à toutes ces questions républicain voilà
c'est ma réponse
monsieur le sénateur Segouin
[Musique]
oui je n'ai pas du mal à me relire je
n'ai pas je n'ai pas annoncé à Monsieur
cifaoui en rendez-vous qu'il aurait une
subvention je l'ai je dis tout à l'heure
que c'était faux je pense je pense que
Monsieur préfet Gravel a dû mal
comprendre ou qu'il y a une
incompréhension dans la manière dont les
choses se sont dites entre monsieur
Sifaoui et Monsieur le Préfet Gravel
mais je suis formelle il n'est pas
possible et les éléments matériels le
démontrent agenda message etc je n'ai
pas reçu Monsieur cifaoui dans mon
bureau en mars pour lui annoncer une
subvention donc je dément cela et
l'effet démontre que ce n'est pas
possible
monsieur le sénateur Brière
[Musique]
je vais me répéter mais du coup je vais
me répéter extraordinairement rapidement
mais je n'avais pas de raison de
soutenir monsieur cifaoui son projet je
n'avais pas non plus de raison de m'y
opposer à ce moment-là eu égard à ce que
l'on connaissait de cela et je me
permets de répéter puisque je vous ai
entendu excalité demande de la
commission d'enquête dire sur public
c'est là que j'étais ami de Monsieur
Sifaoui et que c'était donc la
République des copains je répète je ne
suis pas copine de Monsieur cifaoui et
que et que je ne suis pas copine de
Monsieur Sifaoui monsieur le sénateur
bilac sur les clubs sportifs français
vous avez
absolument raison sur le rôle absolument
fondamental joué par les clubs sportifs
c'est pour ça que certaines activités
sportives d'ailleurs sont financées par
le FIPD au titre de la prévention de la
radicalisation de la délinquance etc et
je suis je tiens à souligner que le fond
Marianne à vocation à soutenir du
discours en ligne sur les réseaux
sociaux et on y reviendra parce que
c'est important pour un des autres
sujets que nous allons aborder je pense
tout à l'heure mais le but du fond
Marianne n'est pas de financer des
activités sportives ces activités elles
sont déjà financées par ailleurs sur
d'autres lignes budgétaires donc ce
n'est pas son objet et j'ai souri quand
vous avez dit il faut pas jeter le bébé
avec l'eau du bain parce que c'est ce
que je répète depuis des semaines et
qu'effectivement je crois aussi que
cette politique publique de lutte contre
le cyber islamisme les fondamentale qui
ne faut pas la cesser et qu'il ne faut
pas effectivement jeter le bébé avec
l'eau du bain je vous rejoins
parfaitement et pour conclure pour cette
première salle je me suis le sénateur
est longue la question de la doctrine
elle est fondamentale je vous rejoins
complètement et d'ailleurs nous avons
nous avions initié un travail de
doctrine confié au sgcpdr pour dire
pardon
à tous les acronymes de la région je
vous prie de m'excuser le secrétariat
général du Comité intermittal de
prévention de la délinquance et de la
radicalisation pardon pour l'acronyme
nous avons nous avions confié le travail
sur cette sur cette doctrine et il y a
deux sujets que je souhaite ici
distinguer qui sont les sujets là ici et
les sujets font Marianne le sujet font
mariage le fond Marianne il est pas là
pour alimenter des débats de ligne
autour des questions de laïcité il est
vraiment là pour porter un discours
républicain et définir ce qui nous
rassemblent face à des discours
notamment de radicalisation donc il y a
une doctrine sur le cyber islamiste qui
est réalisé par les services du
ministère de l'Intérieur en charge de
cela et une doctrine fond Marianne qui
donne lieu à l'appel à projet réalisé
par l'USG cipdr j'imagine que les
travaux sont à mon avis dans les
archives qui sont à disposition j'espère
avoir répondu à l'ensemble des questions
se trouver venez de parler d'appel à
projet je vais revenir 16 avril 2021 un
mail du directeur de cabinet de votre
directeur de cabinet au secrétaire
général du cpdr indique que la durée de
l'appel à projet doit être raccourci et
avancé finalement ça devrait se tenir en
trois semaines initialement le préfet
nous a dit elle l'habitude c'était trois
mois et il doit avoir lieu le mail et du
16 avril en trois semaines entre le 20
avril donc 4 jours après et le 10 mai
alors qu'il était
initialement prévu qu'il se déroule
entre le 1er mai et le 30 juin ce qui
était déjà plus court que le delà
habituel et est-ce que
l'appel à projet a donc été
lancé quatre jours après
ce mail avez-vous été de près ou de loin
partie prenante de cette décision quelle
raison explique cette
accélération du calendrier et ce que
vous pensez à ce stade aujourd'hui avec
une un certain recul que finalement
c'était un bon délai suffisant et
permettant de bien conduire cet appel à
projet choix original que vous avez
explicité l'orientation
oui monsieur le rapporteur sur la
question du calendrier dans le cadre de
l'appel à projet je ne me suis pas
personnellement mêlée de la mise en
oeuvre et de l'ingénierie des
dispositifs ce que je sais en revanche
c'est que il n'y a aucune alerte qui me
remonte de la part de l'administration
quant à cédé j'ai regardé et je n'ai pas
une note ou une alerte
écrite ou matérielle de l'administration
disant que ce délai n'est pas tenable et
que donc il préconise un autre délai
parce qu'ils ne sauront pas faire dans
ce délai le délai trois semaines pour
recueillir les candidatures c'est vrai
qu'il peut paraître contraint il est
serré ce délai mais il nous apparaissait
adapter au regard de la mobilisation qui
était organisée depuis des mois puisque
je rappelle et ces documentés que ça
fait plusieurs mois à ce moment-là que
j'ai impuissé cette cette demande de
création du fond Marianne il y a des
réflexions qui étaient en cours on en a
parlé depuis l'automne et le sgcpdr
pouvez aussi s'appuyer sur justement
l'ensemble de ces de ces travaux de ces
entretiens menés avec les experts depuis
l'automne j'ajoute qu'on a mobilisé et
ce dans un contexte de diminution des
effectifs en administration centrale au
ministère de l'intérieur on a réussi à
mobiliser pour le SG cippr 17
recrutement supplémentaire au 20 avril
ça donne à penser qu'il y a des moyens
humains suffisants dans l'administration
à ce moment-là pour tenir les délais et
j'ajoute pour conclure que les délais
courts ils n'ont pas semblé posé de
difficultés particulières dans la mesure
où il y a eu 71 dossiers qui ont été
présentés dans ce délai pour candidater
à cet appel à projet ça ne les a pas
empêché de candidater si vous voulez mon
avis mais ça n'est qu'un avis 71 pour un
appel à projet national c'est-à-dire
moins d'un par département sachant que
vous avez déjà des opérateurs on peut
considérer que si vous considérez que
c'est une réussite on peut considérer
qu'elle est au moins en demi teinte
à la fois de donner des éléments
d'éclaircissement donc en fait ce qui
continue de m'étonner je vous le dis
vous n'êtes jamais à l'origine de la
décision vous la prenez c'est votre
administration le cabinet ne vous alerte
pas vous dites j'ai pas de note ça
s'accélère oui il faut aller vite 4
jours après on décide
20 jours après la décision
est prise finalement ça ne nuit pas
c'est ce que j'en conclus c'est délai
très resserrés à la qualité de la
sélection aux procédures à respecter
pour avoir à la fois une transparence
des grilles d'analyse pour ensuite
pouvoir en toute connaissance de cause
avec un jury le plus averti possible
procéder à une sélection sachant
néanmoins le président rénal l'a rappelé
on voit bien qu'il y a quand même dans
les acteurs qui travaillaient jusqu'à
maintenant
en bon intelligence avec le gouvernement
est dans le cadre du FIPD que certains
vont forcément être intéressés candidaté
c'est leur liberté voilà il y aura plus
ou moins de fléchages donc finalement
tout ça n'a pas mis cette accélération
ça peut-être même permis d'avoir une
meilleure qualité de réponse c'est
d'être plus performant avec une
méthodologie bien cadrée c'est ce que
vous pensez aujourd'hui
monsieur le rapporteur moi je n'ai que
mon humble avis mais
bien sûr
plus dans la même responsabilité ça
n'empêche pas d'avoir des humbles agis
que je que je partage avec vous
aujourd'hui sur le nombre de dossiers
reçus j'ai c'est mon troisième ministère
ça fait c'est ma 7e année que j'exerce
des responsabilités ministérielles
j'étais adjoint au maire précédemment
j'ai aussi participer à de nombreux
appels à projets où j'en ai impulsé et
71 réponses pour un sujet par des
mémoire expression mais de niche c'est
important il ne s'agit pas là d'un appel
à projet auquel le tout venant peut
répondre il s'agit d'un appel à projet
qui s'adresse à des experts de la lutte
contre la radicalisation
spécifiquement sur les réseaux sociaux
ou en ligne donc on est 71 personnes
structures qui soient touchées et qui
répondent moi je trouve que c'est un
nombre important je ne vous dis pas que
tout a été bien fait parce qu'il est
documenté aujourd'hui que ce n'est pas
le cas donc bien sûr les choses auraient
pu être faites différemment mieux faites
et je disais tout à l'heure vos retours
d'expérience nous dirons en quel sens
dans l'avenir nous pourrons mieux
ficeler cela mais à ce moment là bien
sûr c'est le cas je veux dire également
que ce que la façon monsieur rapporteur
dont vous présentez les choses laisse à
penser que que je subirai les fesses
sauf votre espèce sur l'interprétation
de ce que vous dites je rappelle pas
encore le rôle de chacun
le ministre suit bien sûr les commandes
politiques et les dossiers qu'il a
impulsé auprès de l'administration mais
n'est pas là encore dans la mise en
oeuvre au jour le jour ou dans
l'ingénierie ce que veut savoir le
ministre c'est si ça avance si les
sujets débouche sont pris en main sont
traités si on est sur le ballon et pas
nécessairement quelle est la date de
rendu de la première étape des porteurs
de projets c'est en tout cas ma manière
de faire elle est peut-être pas bonne
mais en tout cas c'est la manière dont
je suis les choses à ce moment là madame
simplement quand on dit on a 71 réponses
ça montre que le temps était suffisant
quand on regarde donc et votre directeur
de cabinet d'ailleurs avait regardé un
petit peu un éclairage donc il y a 54
sur 71 qui sont pas retenus donc on
verra que sur certains il y a des
questions à vous poser mais pour
l'essentiel ce sont des projets qui sont
tout simplement hors sujets des rapports
qui sont hors sujet c'est à dire c'est
un sujet sur la mise en ligne et les
réseaux sociaux comment on fait du
contre discours sur les réseaux sociaux
et on vous répond à ces
traditionnellement sur des actions du
FIPD donc vous avez déjà 54 qui passe à
la trappe au moins une cinquantaine on
va dire d'autres répuls peut-être être
retenues mais 54 et sur les 17 il y en a
que 5
finalement en dehors des des deux gros
dont on parle pour l'essentiel il y en a
que cinq autres si vous voulez qui sont
nouveaux donc le reste c'est des réseaux
sociaux comme l'habitude de travailler
avec les supers qui ont le temps de
répondre à ça et de modifier et aussi
parce qu'ils ont en contact du cpda
permanent et donc ils ajustent leur
propositions ils ont un petit peu plus
pour faire des actions dans ce domaine
donc vous voyez que au résultat de cet
appel d'offre et la la raison c'est sans
doute que ce domaine pas facile mais
aussi la raison c'est que le délai est
tellement court que ni répondre que ceux
qui sont déjà connus du site PDR et puis
quelques toutes petites associations qui
proposent des tout petits projets et que
finalement il y a deux gros projets qui
arrivent sur le bureau et ces deux
projets n'arrivent pas de manière de la
manière
identique aux autres c'est à dire que
l'un vient on y revient pas mais on le
réaffirme par votre cabinet et l'autre
vient plutôt par le cipdr lui-même qui a
eu ce contact avec une association et
qui souhaite la pousser ou l'aider voilà
donc il faut bien voir que tout ça
que vous pouvez pas dire il y a eu 71
réponses et donc c'est très bon non il y
a eu beaucoup de réponses hors-jeu voilà
l'essentiel
raison pour laquelle je disais plutôt un
bilan en demi teinte madame la ministre
alors je veux vous mettre
parfaitement et à l'aise et sereine je
crois pas avoir jusqu'à maintenant
fait passer le message comme quoi je
penserai ou pourrait croire que vous
subissiez l'effet je pense au contraire
votre parcours vous venez de le rappeler
une expérience ministérielle
démontre plutôt que vous avez une
capacité à faire face à beaucoup de
responsabilités et je dirais même à
toutes les situations vous êtes voilà
aujourd'hui
dans un temps où vous répondez à un
questionnement je le redis vous l'avez
dit à de multiples reprises d'ailleurs
sous serment nous on essaie on a à cœur
de vouloir faire la lumière comprendre
et on va s'en tenir si vous voulez bien
à ça
est-ce que vous aviez toujours sur appel
à projet déjà rencontré
certains des lauréats avant même le la
création du fond Marianne est-ce que
vous aviez eu des échanges oui avec
certains vous l'avez dit Monsieur
Sifaoui et avec reconstruire le commun
à ma connaissance monsieur rapporteur je
n'ai pas reçu les responsables de
l'association reconstruire le commun
pour être tout à fait honnête avec vous
j'ai pas en tête la totalité des noms ou
des visages des gens qui ont pris part à
ce projet puisque j'ai cru comprendre
qu'il y avait des porteurs de projets et
des prestataires ou des bénévoles au
sein du projet qui était intervenu ce
que je peux dire c'est que j'ai pas de
relation antérieure ou personnelle avec
elle ou eux mais je peux vous certifier
de les avoir jamais croisé dans quelques
endroits que ce soit ou même ni même je
ne sais pas si je les ai reçus sous
d'autres casquettes en tout cas j'ai pas
souvenir de les avoir reçus mais ça veut
pas dire que ce que ce soit impossible
reconstruire le commun fait partie le
président Arnal vient de l'évoquer de
des associations qui ont reçu de fortes
dotations c'est une association qui
était de création récente puisque elle
avait été créée en toute fin d'année
2020 et que même le versement le
préversement de 39000 euros j'appellerai
le l'appui à la création
avait été versée comment dirais-je au
tout début de l'année 2021 on a parlé de
l'uspm sur le manque d'expérience
finalement des sommes importantes dans
les deux cas sur des associations
US EPM avec un petit budget convenance
en 50000 euros une reconstruire le
commun une association toute nouvelle
portée sur les fonds bâtissements avec
le soutien de l'État 39000 euros à qui
vous avez attribué donc des
montants importants des subventions Sana
provoqué
pas d'alerte ça n'a pas provoqué
d'alerte particulière au sein de votre
équipe on va parvenir sur les
normissimes mais parce que comme ils
obtiendront quand même et même davantage
que les 300 000 et reconstruire le
commun il y a il y a des il y a des
trous dans les mailles
est-ce que vous pouvez du coup rajouter
la question de Monsieur Hublet à ce
stade
dans le même dans le même domaine oui
bien sûr alors peut-être commencer
monsieur
cette part vous répondre le projet du
fond Marianne c'est aussi et c'est
pourquoi nous faisons aussi cet appel à
projet au-delà de la volonté d'être
transparent à ce moment-là c'est de
faire émerger aussi de nouveaux acteurs
et justement de tâcher de ne pas
travailler qu'avec celles et ceux qui
sont connues du cipdr le but c'est de
toucher la jeunesse sur les réseaux
sociaux et donc de pouvoir aussi
soutenir des acteurs émergents parce
qu'il y a un caractère un peu innovant
ou expérimental à ce contre discours je
mets des guillemets des précautions
républicain
et moi j'ai pas souvenir d'avoir été
informé ou alerté sur les 39 ke que
demande reconstruire le commun
il y a un montant de subvention qui je
comprends est lié aux besoins de
recrutement ou de formation aux médias
en tout cas c'est ce que je recoupe
aujourd'hui dans les dans les documents
mais je ne prends pas part et je n'ai
pas d'alerte sur le montant de la
subvention pour reconstruire le commun
je sais pas si vous avez d'autres
questions par rapport à cela
non je voudrais simplement dire puisque
vous avez évoqué les moyens dont vous
disposiez les renforts en personnels
juste pour que nos collègues et c'est
les ceux qui suivent cette audition soit
parfaitement informée à ma connaissance
l'instruction des dossiers étaient sous
la responsabilité d'une seule personne
raison pour laquelle je continue de
m'interroger sur la solidité de la
méthode sa transparence c'est peut-être
d'ailleurs ce qui a amené je le rappelle
l'igéa a considéré que l'appel à projet
n'avait été ni transparent ni équitable
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Rapporteur simplement porter à votre
connaissance le fait que moi j'ai appris
que les dossiers du fond Marianne
étaient gérés par une personne une seule
personne et qui je crois exercent comme
chargé de mission au cpdr je l'ai appris
au cours du rapport de l'hygia et des
auditions qui ont été menées dans cette
commission d'enquête nous nous avions
obtenu les arbitrages politiques
nécessaires avec mon cabinet pour
renforcer un moyen humain
considérablement le cipdr et donc
notamment cette action de contrediscours
républicain merci madame la ministre
mais je rappelle aussi que
après les événements très graves qui est
sont à l'origine de la création du fond
Marianne le gouvernement avait mis une
communication puissante notamment par
vous-même pour expliquer qu'il allait
agir et monter au combat donc je
simplement je ne peux pas vous laisser
dire de manière placide que vous
découvrez après je pense qu'un ou une
ministre lorsqu'il est en action qui
décide d'un plan d'action et de combat
pour lutter contre les séparatismes
notamment sur les réseaux sociaux il
s'assure de la mise en oeuvre parce que
quand vous faites une annonce sur une
telle politique il y avait une telle
ambition il s'agit pas après que ça se
dégonfle un peu comme un ballon de
baudruche je pense que c'est en tous les
cas ça n'a jamais été j'imagine dans la
tête de personne voilà c'est tout c'est
il y a une distorsion assez importante
entre les moyens
consacrés à l'examen des candidatures
sur un temps très court resserré avec
une mise en action hyper rapide c'est le
constat je dirais factuel que je dresse
à cet instant
bien sûr merci Monsieur rapporteur je me
bien sûr c'est votre appréciation elle
est parfaitement légitime je me permets
de rappeler que
alors je ne la trouve pas exactement ce
rapporteur avec tout le respect que j'ai
pour vous-même personnellement et pour
la commission plus généralement et enfin
c'est mon avis et c'est pourquoi je me
permets de vous répondre le fond
Marianne
c'est une petite partie des politiques
publiques qui sont menées par le
gouvernement en général et par votre
serviteur en particulier sur la question
de la lutte contre le terreau du
terrorisme j'ai évoqué très rapidement
quelques exemples dans mon propos
liminaire et je ne vais pas par respect
pour le temps qui nous est en partie
déroulé la totalité de la politique
publique mais vous savez que par exemple
l'action de renfort de Pharo c'est
absolument fondamental Faro ce n'est pas
ouvert 24 heures sur 24 et 7 jours sur 7
à ce moment-là nous obtenons des
arbitrages nécessaires au plus haut
niveau pour faire ouvrir Pharos 24
heures sur 24 et 7 jours sur 7 pour que
des pouvoirs importants nous mobilisons
les plateformes les réseaux sociaux nous
réactivons une initiative qui avait été
lancée par Monsieur Miss Bernard
Cazeneuve à l'époque pour avoir une
instance de dialogue avec les
plateformes et les réseaux sociaux pour
pouvoir communiquer notamment des
informations à l'enquête quand il y a
des contenus d'incitation au terroristes
qui sont portés il y a toute une action
législative qui va avec je n'apprends
pas au parlementaire parce que vous
savez vous avez pris par à ces débats
notamment sur la clause portée par
Monsieur ministre de la Justice et
monsieur le ministre de l'Intérieur sur
le fait qu'il est désormais pénalement
répréhensible de communiquer des
éléments des informations personnelles
contre une personne en ligne Hue égard à
une menace islamiste sous-jacente
j'arrête là ma liste mais en fait la
communication portée et que je porte
c'est juste avec force et que je
tâcherai de continuer à porter avec
force elle ne porte pas que sur le fond
Marianne c'est une accroche avec une
autre politique publique
portant sur le fond Marianne je vais
vous faire une dernière réponse la
personne que j'évoquais la personne
ressource était également membre du
comité de sélection je rappelle que dans
ce com ité de sélection il y avait
également trois membres de votre cabinet
donc là j'ai une vraie difficulté avec
trois membres de votre cabinet vous ne
pouviez pas
ignoriez ignorer pardon la difficulté
pour une seule personne à inscrire les
dossiers et vous le saviez en temps réel
monsieur le rapporteur avec je ne savais
pas d'ailleurs le rapport hygial le
documente et je vous inviterai à le dire
la charge émission qui est que vous avez
je crois auditionner qui avait demandé
d'après ce que dit le rapport j'en ai
pas connaissance je rapporte maintenant
c'est propos là semble avoir demandé un
renfort renfort qui avait été refusé par
sa hiérarchie au niveau administratif et
donc l'iggia c'est pour ça qu'elle
qualifie cela de manque de discernement
de la part de la personne qui a refusé
les moyens mais il y a aucun moment ça
ne remonte jusqu'à moi et je ne crois
pas jusqu'à mon cabinet le fait qu'il y
ait un manque de moyens
ce que vous dites vous êtes en train de
nous dire qu'avec trois membres de votre
cabinet vous n'êtes au courant de rien
sur comment dirais-je une séquence de
trois semaines d'un fond Marianne dont
vous déclarez l'urgence agir voilà je
monsieur le rapporteur non mais je tire
simplement un enseignement de la réalité
de fait et d'actes qui sont reportés et
rapportés par des voies diverses au
cours des auditions c'est tout je
propose qu'on poursuive si vous si vous
stressegent avec le directeur
d'administration et encore aujourd'hui
dans des dossiers dont j'ai la
responsabilité je ne demande pas aux
directeur de l'administration quel est
le nom des personnes qui sont en train
d'instruire telle ou tel dossier au sein
de l'administration ça n'est pas le rôle
du Miss je termine nous partageons votre
réponse mais c'est pas la question
voilà
on parle la question la question c'est
de dire dans le comité de sélection il y
avait trois membres de votre cabinet qui
était informé ne fût-ce que par la
chargée de mission en question qu'il a
dit clairement devant truc il y avait
une difficulté à gérer le nombre de
dossiers etc voilà ça aurait pu remonter
c'est toujours cette fameuse relation
cabinet
ministre qui est un peu toujours un trou
noir malgré tout
voilà c'est là dessus que ça repose mais
on entend votre réponse
alors quelques réponses
questions qui vont appeler les
rencontres très rapides et puis on
reviendra sur des sujets un peu plus
d'abord il nous avait été dit que vous
deviez initialement participer au comité
de sélection du 21 mai c'est-à-dire du
fond Marianne alors peut-être pour
l'ouvrir peut-être pour être présente
tout le temps en tout cas ça ne se fait
pas quels sont les raisons
[Applaudissements]
alors le lien bien sûr nous intéresse
toujours
dans l'échelle de connaissances du
dossier vous l'avez dit le fond Marianne
c'est un élément parmi bien d'autres
plus important en tout cas
farose voilà donc des sujets très
importants de ce plan général voulu par
le Président de la République et le
gouvernement ensuite
et qui ne fait pas de qui n'appelle pas
de commentaires particuliers tant nous
sommes dans une période particulière bon
est-ce que vous avez d'une façon ou
d'une autre est-ce que ça a été l'objet
de discussion avec votre Ministre
tutelle monsieur Gérald Darmanin et si
oui sur quoi ça a apporté est-ce qu'il
était informé ensuite rapidement des
difficultés qui sont apparues
monsieur le Président traditionnellement
il y a des points de rencontre entre mon
directeur de cabinet et le directeur de
cabinet de mon livre de tutelle c'est à
cette occasion qu'ils échangent sur à la
fois des comptes rendus ou des demandes
ou des des feedbacks si j'ose dire
d'activités menées par mon cabinet
donc le coin qui nous a vous le savez
qui chagrine tout le monde en réalité y
compris les géants c'est qu'il n'y a eu
aucune grille de notation pour la
sélection des projets en réalité
on a pratiqué comme il s'agissait de
financement à la main du politique
et non pas d'un appel à projet un appel
à projet alors vous avez de cette
assistance vous l'avez compris vous le
savez beaucoup d'anciens maires
d'anciens présidents de départements etc
j'en passe de collectivités alors
lorsqu'une municipalité lance un appel à
projet
elle est tenue par des règles
sur un appel à projet et notamment
les appels à projet
débouche sur plusieurs points qui sont
assez clairs d'abord comment dire un
comité assez ouvert assez large
souvent on recommande que le maire
d'ailleurs ne préside pas bon c'est une
prudence bon et puis ensuite il y a
forcément une grille de notation et qui
est ensuite qui donne lieu à une
communication et généralement un retour
vers les associations ou ou les
entreprises quand il s'agit
d'entreprises non sélectionnés
alors dans ce cas précis
le point qui est extraordinaire c'est
qu'il y a rien
rien alors comment il y avait rien on a
redemandé plusieurs fois parce qu'on se
dit rien possible il y a un truc enfin
bon on distribue pas de l'argent public
sans faire un petit rapport
un écrit d'un rapport il y a même pas
sur le comité de sélection il y a même
pas un rapport simple que il y a juste
une liste d'associations avec le montant
retenu et en plus nous le savons ce
montant il a été fait sur Excel pour
dire les choses et il a pu être même
modifié après le comité de sélection
nous y reviendrons donc on est sur
quelque chose de totalement alors quand
l'hygia a dit que c'est pas transparent
la transparence ça se traduit par tout
simplement à minima par un compte-rendu
qui précise les choses qui précise les
éléments qui vendent différenciation on
met en place une grille différenciation
on explique etc généralement aussi il y
a un règlement administratif qui démarre
c'est à dire que avant de répondre à la
question est-ce que vous pouvez c'est
est-ce que vous êtes en situation et
donc c'est toutes les règles
administratives c'est la question de
Vincent et Blais sur l'ancienneté de
l'association etc toutes ces questions
sont généralement dans une première
partie et si l'entreprise l'association
les entreprises parce que pour les
Mairies c'est les entreprises souvent si
on franchise cap on peut ensuite
effectivement
être parti prenante de l'appel d'offre
bon voilà dans ce cas précis c'est pas
du tout le cas rien de rien de rien de
rien
alors vous pouvez dire madame je sais
pas comme vous l'avez dit un peu comme
vous avez à votre façon lorsque vous
avez reçu le rapport de l'hygiène et que
vous avez commenté le rapport de l'hygia
au-delà du fait que vous prenez la
garantie de dire que vous ne le
commentez pas mais la précaution logique
mais de fait vous dites
en gros le rapport de déjà dit que je
n'ai rien à me reprocher bon donc
en réalité vous avez un moment donné en
combien de sélection dans lequel il y a
la moitié des membres qui sont de votre
cabinet qui participent à une sélection
qui ne donne lieu à aucun document de
restitution qui ne donne lieu à aucun
élément d'appréciation du choix des
associations qui ne donne même pas lieu
à une analyse préalable permettant de
dire à ce que telle ou telle association
peut répondre on a bien compris que le
premier projet
l'uspm c'est un premier projet
entre guillemets Sifaoui
comment dire abriter par l'uspm en
réalité
il fallait que ce soit une association
qui réponde et pas une personne physique
et donc du SPPM apparaît tout d'un coup
dans le paysage bon il faut voilà mais
on n'est pas en cause l'uspm on regarde
pas c'est comment dire ces statues on
regarde pas
financier ses capacités à faire on ne
regarde rien et on fait même sujet pour
reconstruire le commun ou en réalité on
est sur une association qui vient de
démarrer qui n'a aucun passé et qui rien
que pour ça pour ces raisons-là n'aurait
pu jamais pu
pouvoir trouver ailleurs ou peut-être ou
que ce soit plus de 300.000 euros de
subventions ça n'existe nulle part et
c'est bien le sujet donc on a bien
là-dessus
excusez-moi de le dire
est-ce que vous considérez après
maintenant en voyant le résultat de tout
ça est-ce que vous considérez que cette
absence d'outils objectifs
d'appréciation est normal
est-ce que vous trouvez normal qu'il n'y
ait aucun
compte-rendu de réaliser
ni même un relevé de décision argumenté
rien du tout est-ce que ça vous paraît
de bonnes pratiques et est-ce habituelle
dans les administrations que vous
connaissez
merci monsieur le Président j'identifie
quatre questions au moins voir 5 je vais
essayer d'être
concise
la première chose d'abord bien sûr
souscrit à ce que vous disiez monsieur
le Président sur la constitution des
attributions de subvention dans les
collectivités j'ai eu l'honneur d'être
adjointe au sénateur maire du Mans
pendant quelques années j'avais moi-même
à attribuer des subventions
absolument mer adjointe auprès de
Jean-Claude Boulard qui était sénateur
mergement et j'avais moi-même créé un
Comité d'attribution des subventions
très larges pour justement balayer les
subventions qui avaient pas de pouvoir
de décision mais qui avait encore de
consultation qui était ensuite transmis
à l'administration sous ma présidence
je veux dire cependant qui n'existe à ma
connaissance pas de règles écrites sur
la composition des comités de sélection
d'appels à projets et donc à ce moment
là de mon point de vue nous sommes en
toute bonne foi dans le respect des
règles de financement et des règles
écrites qui existent dans dans ce cadre
les membres de mon cabinet qui sont
membres du comité de sélection vous
voulez que j'aille plus vite
les membres de mon cabinet qui sont dans
le comité de sélection sont pour deux
d'entre eux des anciens membres du cipdr
ils ont travaillé ils sont experts de
ces questions
reconnus et c'est pourquoi il me semble
pas incohérent à ce moment là de bonne
foi une fois encore que c'est conseillé
capé sur le sujet qui connaissent
l'écosystème participent et travaillent
avec ce comité la paix il a pour nous un
cadre d'éligibilité c'est le cadre et
les conditions de la paix qui est
publiée que chacun a qui était public il
prévoit pas effectivement vous avez tout
à fait raison monsieur le Président de
notification de refus en revanche chaque
projet a fait l'objet d'une fiche que
vous avez eu d'évaluation de son projet
qui synthétise me semble le dossier et
bien évidemment
en retour d'expérience et alors c'est à
posteriori eu égard à tous les éléments
dont nous disposons aujourd'hui bien
évidemment il y a des règles même si
elles ne sont pas des règles de droit
qui sont des usages ou des bonnes
pratiques qu'ils pourraient être utile
de clarifier et c'est pourquoi je vous
disais dans mon propos liminaire je suis
très demandeuse des retours d'expérience
et des préconisations que fera votre
commission d'enquête y compris étant
aujourd'hui chargé de la vie associative
et donc quelque part de l'encadrement
des liens entre
l'administration et l'État et les
associations si nous pouvons clarifier
peut-être par du réglementaire les
règles d'organisation de communauté de
sélection afin d'aller vers plus de
transparence et de ne pas être dans
l'usuel mais dans le règlement je pense
que ça serait tout à fait précieux c'est
en tout cas mon avis vous avez parlé de
fiche d'évaluation sur chacune des ça
c'est pas tout ce qu'on a eu nous c'est
des fiches de description de projet et
ensuite il y avait une évaluation qui a
été faite par la recharger de mission
devant le comité de sélection évidemment
je pense que cela a eu lieu mais nous
n'avons pas connaissance mais on peut
imaginer qu'il y a eu de la part du slip
et d'ailleurs un exposé sur chaque cas
ça a dû être fait bien entendu parce que
sinon alors
on qui ressort quoi donc voilà donc
forcément il y a eu quelque chose de
cette nature mais
j'insiste sur ce point des fonds d'État
c'est autre chose que des fois
associatifs municipaux les fonds
associatifs municipaux ça peut se régler
d'ailleurs assez vite si ça crée des
histoires et des scandales si vous
voulez le maire et et à quelques
difficultés à être réélu vous voyez ce
que je veux dire donc il y a des
précautions qui sont prises souvent dans
les collectivités surtout ces aspects
pour être bien au clair parce qu'il y a
rien de pire les mères le savent qu'une
association sportive qui dit mais
celle-là a eu je sais pas pourquoi moi
j'ai eu que 10000 donc vous savez on
s'embrasse pas avec ça plus on est
transparent sur ces sujets mieux c'est
et quand il s'agit de fonds publics là
aussi alors
d'autres d'autres questions certaines
associations ont une subvention accordée
inférieure à leur demande
par ailleurs par exemple qui
s'associants qu'on demande des 130 000
euros d'un an obtenu que 70 000 alors
que l'année précédente elles avaient
obtenu 140000 euros comme il n'y a aucun
compte rendu de quoi que ce soit on met
tout en doute ou en question vous le
comprenez donc comment expliquer vous ce
point de votre de votre point de vue
dans le dans le cas précis il s'agit
d'une association
et le
les seuls commentaires que nous avons pu
avoir sur sur ces questions c'est la
question que finalement ces associations
qui ont eu moins été considérés comme
souvent par comme un peu gentillette
voilà c'est-à-dire ayant une vision de
la laïcité comment dire douce
travaillant plutôt sur comment dire
l'esprit de fraternité que sur comment
dire un discours plus
plus raide par rapport au sujet un peu
tel que finalement vous l'avez pas que
vous mais globalement en tant que
politiquementale poussez mais ce qui ce
qui chagrine souvent ces associations
qui ont eu des baisses souvent la
motivation orale qui a pu être donné ici
ou là c'était effectivement que j'étais
considéré comme pas tout à fait dans la
vision
budget gouvernementale il y a même une
fiche qui le dit de manière explicite
mais vous voyez à ces associations là
rien ne leur a été répondu après tout
une position politique de cette nature
peut tout à fait s'exprimer
et une ligne politique a été clairement
affichée par le gouvernement et donc
après tout dire vous n'êtes plus vous
n'êtes pas aujourd'hui finalement dans
cette ligne que nous voulons pousser à
travers ça peut s'entendre mais comme
c'est pas dit
on sait pas si c'est le fait du prince
ou autre chose
qu'est-ce que vous pouvez nous en dire
monsieur le Président sincèrement j'ai
pas d'éléments à partager sur ce sujet
j'ai pas fait partie de ces discussions
moi je trouve pas que ce soit négatif de
soutenir une association qui défendent
les principes de fraternité ça fait
partie des valeurs de la République de
la trilogie républicaine je j'ai en tout
cas formulé aucune demande en ce sens et
j'ai pas connaissance d'échanges qui
peuvent exister visant à dire qu'on va
baisser une demande pour ces raisons
donc en tout cas nous vous l'apprenons
ça a pu être le cas
donc quelles sont les raisons qui vous
ont conduit à exclure un certain nombre
d'associations lors de la sélection des
projets
alors on a dit certaines étaient
totalement hors jeu enfin il ne répondez
pas au sujet elles étaient très
nombreuses d'autres c'est un peu plus
délicat et notamment on revient à ça
est-ce que finalement mais vous
m'envoyez répondu alors bon je peux m'en
tenir à ça est-ce que finalement le fait
de pas être dans la ligne
gouvernementale telle qu'elle est
définie publiquement il y a rien de
secret sur la ligne elle l'affichage bon
fait que certaines associations ne
répondent plus finalement même si elle
travaille sur la laïcité ne répondent
plus à vos demandes en tout cas elle ne
correspondent pas à l'esprit du fond
Marianne
monsieur le Président je vais vous
répondre dans mon point de vue à cet
égard mais qui ne présage pas des enfin
qui ne signifie rien au regard des
discussions d'arbitrage puisque une fois
encore je n'ai pas participé au comité
de sélection en revanche je veux
distinguer deux choses je distinguer
l'action politique du gouvernement et la
ligne de politique publique mise en
oeuvre
il est tout à fait permis
j'allais dire recommander j'aurais
peut-être jusque là mais en tout cas
elle est tout à fait permi à des
associations d'être en désaccord avec la
politique gouvernementale et d'ailleurs
je dans les ministères dont j'ai eu la
charge j'en ai financé et j'en finance
encore et c'est en aucun cas un motif de
diminution de demandes de subvention par
rapport à ces associations ça c'est pour
l'action politique ensuite en termes de
politique publique et donc non
politicienne il y a là effectivement une
volonté de travailler à la lutte contre
la radicalisation et donc à défendre les
valeurs de la République et donc par
nature mais encore une fois j'ai pas
participé aux discussions je dis ça pour
éclairer ce qui à mon avis peut procéder
à cela je vous donne un exemple une
association qui dirait que il y a que le
l'État français est un état raciste
structurellement moi je considère qui
serait difficile de lui confier l'action
de porter un discours républicain en
ligne qui vise à défendre les
institutions et la République c'est un
exemple que je vous donne un avis
politique personnel que je donne
aujourd'hui pour éclairer peut-être les
discussions mais qui ne ça ne veut pas
dire que ce soit ça qui était qui était
discuté je sais pas si je suis claire
dans vous êtes toujours clair madame
merci
tout ceci voyez aurait mérité
parce que ce que vous dites n'est pas
scandaleux
en mérité une précision un éclairage et
dans un rapport que ce soit écrit oui il
y a pas de il y a pas de difficulté ce
n'est pas le cas donc tout peut être
interrogé
je voudrais évidemment revenir
sur un sujet que vous connaissez
donc vous avez été informé et et quand
notamment citer votre directeur de
cabinet qui est un point important qui
est finalement la suppression d'une
subvention à une association qui est
depuis a été cité par la presse elle
n'avait pas été un audition mais c'est
SOS Racisme
et simplement vous dire qu'il y a
y a là-dessus plusieurs aspects qui sont
étonnants et quelquefois un peu chaud
quand
le premier c'est que
le 25 mai a lieu le comité de sélection
le 25 mai et le 27 mai il y a un mail de
votre membre de votre cabinet
au préfet Gravel en disant j'ai soumis à
la ministre votre note on fait le point
demain
votre note c'est à dire la note
concernant le comté de sélection de la
de la veille
ou de jours avant et juste après vous
prenez une décision qui est prise par
vous selon votre directeur de cabinet
qui est de supprimer une ligne
budgétaire du comité de sélection qui
est celle concernant SOS Racisme je
crois que ça a autant de cent mille
euros de mémoire et qui était elle dans
le comité de sélection donc si vous
voulez on a parlé des problématiques
avant le comité de sélection on a parlé
des problématiques durant le comité de
sélection et même après le comité de
sélection comme il y a toujours pas de
compte-rendu du comité de sélection
en réalité le comité de sélection
je ne sais pas si sélectionne on sait
plus puisque à la sortie comme vous
dites vous validez mais en fait quand
vous validez le résultat du comité de
sélection en réalité vous influez sur le
résultat vous influencer le résultat en
supprimant et et votre directeur de
cabinet a une expression particulière en
indiquant que ces suites d'ailleurs à
des questions personnelles entre
l'expression et pas exactement celle là
mais l'esprit c'est cela
passé entre vous et l'association en
question est-ce que vous pouvez nous
dire
comment les choses se passent dans cette
affaire-là si Monsieur le Directeur de
Cabinet Monsieur le Préfet a eu
à raison de présenter les choses ainsi
est-ce que vous dites non c'est pas le
cas enfin qu'est-ce que vous répondez à
ça
bien sûr monsieur le Président je vous
remercie de me poser la question et me
permettre justement d'apporter des
éléments de d'éclairage je répondrai à
tous les points sans exception d'abord
je vais être très clair je n'ai pas
supprimé de subventions à SOS Racisme je
dis pas que c'est ce que vous avez dit
mais j'ai vu des réponses qui ont été
portées en ce sens disant que mes
décisions auraient mis en péril un
équilibre financier d'une association je
rappelle qu'on est sur un appel à projet
on parle pas de financement ni de
fonctionnement pour les associations
donc je n'enlève pas de l'argent à SOS
racisme dont il bénéficierait chaque
année
alors je vais je vais y revenir mais en
tout cas première élément oui c'est un
peu endroit vous avez raison c'est
subtil comme réponse je pense que le
droit emporte monsieur le Président
d'une part et d'autre part au-delà du
droit quand la réalité est aussi là
c'est à dire vous n'attribuez pas 100000
€ qui avait été sélectionné n'est pas la
même chose que supprimer
je vais vous répondre en essayant d'être
le plus factuel possible dans la mesure
où à titre personnel je n'avais aucun
souvenir du fait qu'il y ait eu des
discussions sur SOS Racisme dans le
cadre du fond Marianne
maintenant qu'on a appelé ce sujet à mon
attention j'ai souvenir qu'il y ait eu
des échanges sur SOS Racisme je me base
sur les faits et sur les échanges écrits
que j'ai pu trouver pour rétablir une
chronologie
ce qu'on veut ce que je comprends
aujourd'hui ce qu'on me dit c'est qu'il
y a une liste établie par le comité de
sélection du fond Marianne avec des
dossiers qui font l'unanimité du comité
de sélection et avec certains qui sont
entre guillemets en liste complémentaire
c'est à dire pour débat je comprends de
ce qu'on me dit aujourd'hui que SOS
Racisme fait partie de cette liste
complémentaire et qu'il n'y a pas
consensus au sein du comité de sélection
et qu'il y a divergences certains
considérants qui ne faut pas attribuer
cette subvention et d'autres considérant
contraire qu'il faut attribuer cette
subvention le point mais m'excusant
c'est pas le compte enfin c'est pas le
compte rendu que nous avons du préfet le
préfet nous dit j'ai simplement demandé
qu'il y ait une réserve sur ce dossier
pour pouvoir vous en parler
personnellement c'est pas la même chose
que de dire qu'il y a un désaccord il y
a pas de désaccord il y a simplement
une précaution de vérification auprès de
vous d'un accord sur le fait qu'on voilà
je comprends bien que ce n'est pas la
même chose Monsieur le Président mais
moi c'est la version que j'ai
aujourd'hui et que je partage avec vous
aujourd'hui d'après ce qu'on me dit
d'après ce que je retrouve dans les
échanges ce qu'on vous dit Madame c'est
ce que vous savez quand même vous
oubliez pas tout de votre vie quand même
je veux dire j'oublie pas toute ma vie
monsieur le Président mais en deux ans
j'ai eu à présider un certain nombre de
réunions à rendre un certain nombre
d'arbitrages et surtout je ne peux pas
me souvenir de réunion auquel je n'ai
pas participé donc l'IGA ou vous-même ou
peut-être même la justice établiront ce
qu'il en est moi je porte à votre
connaissance le fait que aujourd'hui
j'ai une note sur une question de
justice dans ce cas précis on est juste
sur
peu importe mais moi j'essaye de
partager avec vous les éléments
je comprends cela et le point mais
remonter par mon conseiller spécial par
un mail ça s'est établi je l'ai dans
lequel il a il me fait une note que vous
avez si vous n'avez pas vous la passer
dans laquelle il me fait une note en
disant voilà ce sur quoi nous sommes
d'accord et signaler le dossier de SOS
racistes qui manifestement ne trouve pas
de consensus il me demande à moi du coup
de trancher de rendre un arbitrage de
donner un avis favorable ou défavorable
au projet
je pense qu'il sur la question la liste
complémentaire ils sont en liste
complémentaire avant la réunion du
comité de sélection
à la sortie du comité de sélection ils
sont sélectionnés je ne sais pas
actuellement vous faites partie du
comité de sélection je vous le rappelle
vous êtes fait représenter pour des
raisons qui vous sont propres
du comité de sélection juridiquement en
tant que ministre vous faites partie du
comité de sélection comme vous le disiez
monsieur le rapporteur le droit est
important la réalité aussi est
réellement je ne suis pas dans le comité
de sélection je n'ai pas dit que vous
aviez siéger je dis simplement que
juridiquement voilà vous avez vous aviez
pris des disposition pour être membre du
comité de sélection alors en tout cas on
me demande un arbitrage on demande un
avis pour trancher un sujet qui
manifestement d'après ce que j'en
comprends en tout cas ne fait pas
consensus je donne cet avis et il me
semble que le ministre est fondé a donné
un avis favorable ou défavorable quand
son administration ou son cabinet le lui
demande je ne rends pas mon avis tout de
suite
ce dont je dispose je demande une note
sur le projet ce qui démontre bien je ne
rends pas un avis sur une personne et
j'y reviendrai je demande une note sur
le projet pour qu'on puisse voir de quoi
il s'agit dans les notes que j'ai à ma
disposition et vous également
aujourd'hui le projet proposé par
l'association SOS racis qui est par
ailleurs une association tout à fait
respectable et partenaire de l'État et
de différents ministères et encore
aujourd'hui et récemment il est proposé
une action en deux temps l'une sur les
réseaux sociaux et donc qui correspond à
l'objet du fond Marianne et l'autre et
c'est pourquoi je répondais tout à
l'heure à la question de monsieur le
sénateur concerne me semble-t-il des
activités sportives ou physiques dans
certains quartiers or cette proposition
d'action qui vise des qrr c'est à dire
40 quartiers de reconquête républicaine
et donc pas le champ national
contrairement à ce qui est demandé dans
l'appel à projet c'est une action qui
est déjà menée et déjà financée par des
fonds du FIPD par une autre organ qui
s'appelle red aventure et qui fait
exactement ce travail de cohésion de
prévention dans les quartiers
qrr par le biais d'activités sportives
et donc j'imagine que c'est cela qui
amène à ce moment-là a considérer que
l'activité étant or réseau sociaux pour
par importante et de surcroît déjà
couvertes par une autre association
j'aimais manifestement j'en ai pas
souvenir mais manifestement j'ai mis un
avis défavorable en disant que pour moi
ce n'est pas un projet à retenir c'est
un avis que j'aimais et ensuite le
comité de sélection fait une liste
d'après les éléments dont je dispose
dans laquelle de figure pas SOS Racisme
je veux répondre à un élément qui est
fondamental sur ce sujet sur ce qu'a dit
Monsieur le Préfet j'allais qui est un
homme inquiété toute confiance qui a été
mon directeur de cabinet à qui je
referai conscience à l'avenir si j'étais
amené à devoir le faire et qui est un
grand préfet mais mon ancien directeur
de cabinet
feta de relations personnelles de
désaccord personnel que j'aurais avec
monsieur le Président de SOS Racisme je
n'ai pas là non plus on me prête
beaucoup de relations personnelles mais
je n'ai pas de relation personnelle ni
de désaccord personnel ancien ou récents
avec monsieur le Président de SOS
racistes nous avons des désaccords sur
des points
court et qu'il faut avancer
mais reconnaissez que il y a quelque
chose qui va pas vous nous racontez
votre vision des choses
on vous entend
très bien mais nous celles que l'ONA
n'est pas la même donc quand vous dites
d'abord comme vous dites
le préfet j'allais etc j'ai parfaitement
confiance à lui mais il a dit des choses
qui sont fausses globalement c'est ce
que vous dites je ne dis pas que ce sont
des choses
je pense que c'est une interprétation de
sa part ou incompréhension peut-être de
ma faute peut-être de choses que j'ai
exprimé auprès de nos directeur de
cabinet qui l'amène à penser que j'ai un
antérieur personnel avec le président de
SOS racistes ce n'est pas le cas
la question est quand même beaucoup plus
excusez-moi de vous le dire beaucoup
plus simple il y a un comité de
sélection à l'entrée du comité de
sélection il y a des dossiers qui posent
pas de problème on va dire
il y a une liste supplémentaire à la
sortie du comité de sélection il y a
plus de liste supplémentaires c'est
terminé il y a un choix qui a été fait
par le comité de sélection et à ce
moment-là ils sont un peu l'imaginer
dit
attention je fais une réserve sur un des
dossiers de comité de sélection retenu
donc un des dossiers retenus je fais une
réserve parce que je souhaite le
soumettre à la ministre bon alors deux
éléments derrière le premier c'est que
effectivement la remarque qui est faite
c'est une remarque de nature personnelle
et pas une remarque de nature
professionnelle donc ça vous dites le
préfet j'allais à une mauvaise
compréhension du sujet vous n'avez pas
au-delà de ça bon il y a un sujet
peut-être de ma faute j'ai pu être
maladroit dans mon expression c'est tout
à fait possible
tout de même je vais je vais être très
précis madame la ministre je vous ai
effectivement expliqué les montants donc
on a le 20 mai
il y a une note de la chargée de mission
qui est envoyé au cabinet donc vous
n'êtes pas très éloigné qui indique que
le projet pourrait SOS Racisme est
d'accorder 100000 euros je rappelle
puisqu'il y avait questionnements que la
demande initiale était de 140.000 euros
et le premier juin il y a un membre de
votre cabinet qui a adressé un mail
indiquant que lors d'une réunion tenue
le même jour donc le 1er juin il a été
décidé de retirer à SOS Racisme
c'est 100.000 euros et de verser 100 -
80 c'est pas pourquoi 20000 euros au
profit d'une autre association l'effet
la matérialité des faits c'est ça et
uniquement ça
voilà et puis surtout sur l'idée de
voyez bien que sa mère en difficulté
votre position sur finalement
j'ai laissé travailler le comité de
sélection alors c'est vrai dans une
certaine mesure à part qu'il y a eu des
choses qui ont été faites en amont on
l'a dit des choses qui sont faites
pendant le comité de sélection sur
certaines associations qui sont jugées
trop
trop faible enfin en tout cas ne
répondons pas à l'exigence
gouvernementale je vous dis que ce
point-là était
pouvait être entendu et puis ensuite à
la fin à l'après le comité de sélection
alors que la liste était établie et bien
on vient retirer à une association un
montant et ça vient si vous voulez
contredire d'une certaine façon alors
l'idée de dire moi mon rôle c'était de
dire voilà comité de sélection
sélectionne ce qu'on pouvait entendre
parce que votre vous étiez représenté
par votre cabinet déjà dans le comité de
sélection donc
majorité sélectionne et moi je valide et
bien non
vous avez pas validé la vie du comité de
sélection vous avez dit sur une
association ça me convient pas alors
est-ce que le préfet s'est trompé dans
son interprétation
où est-ce qu'il faut retenir votre
interprétation voilà d'une certaine
façon
n'étant pas là c'est pas nous qui
pouvons mais on note une autre quelque
chose de différent voilà monsieur le
Président je pourrais être très clair je
ne dis pas que je n'ai pas donné d'avis
sur SOS Racisme j'ai manifestement donné
un avis négatif sur le projet des SOS
Racisme avis qu'on m'a demandé là où je
dis qu'il y a une différence
d'interprétation
avait déjà eu lieu et que vous
avez été opéré et que vous rangiez à la
vie du comité de sélection vous n'aviez
pas donné un avis sur les les finalement
les associations déjà sélectionnées
monsieur le président
la matérialité des faits le déroulement
vous vous tenez à l'écart mais vous
gardez un regard mm une capacité de
décider les choses sont finalement plus
claires comme ça c'est une manière de
reconnaître que vous avez un pouvoir de
décision tout en vous tenant à l'écart
vous êtes présente pour décider voilà
vous avez
vous avouer
avoir un rôle et une capacité à décider
et à trancher mais c'est mieux de le
dire que de tournicoter autour d'une
décision en expliquant que vous y êtes
mais pas tout à fait vous êtes à côté
c'est logique c'est de ça relève de
votre responsabilité le comité de
sélection comprend pour la moitié des
membres de votre cabinet c'est
parfaitement logique on vous on pourrait
vous reprocher l'inverse bien sûr ce
sont monsieur le rapporteur deux choses
différentes ce n'est pas que je tourne
autour c'est que je tiens à être précise
et si ce n'est pas
je ne sais pas par opposition à
vous-même je permettrai pas de
vous êtes précis monsieur le rapporteur
vos questions sont précises bien
évidemment je tâche de l'être aussi sur
la base des faits dont j'ai souvenir ou
que j'ai matériellement je ne je ne suis
pas dans le comité de sélection mais
quand on demande un avis au ministre le
ministre donne un avis là encore s'il
lui fallut procéder autrement et que
dans les dans les retours d'expérience
et dans les recommandations ou
préconisations que vous ferez vous
considérer que le ministre ne doit pas
rendre un avis ou un arbitrage quand il
lui est demandé sur des subventions
c'est tout à fait entendable et pourquoi
pas mais à ce stade on vient je ne vais
pas d'initiative au comité de sélection
me remonter on me demande un avis je
demande qu'on regarde le projet et je
donne un avis et ensuite le comité
établit une liste finale et je rappelle
que seul le cipdr est fond à mettre les
crédits en paiement ou à attribuer une
finie les subventions de ceux qui font
le périmètre de votre ministère vous
avez la signature donc c'est le ministre
ou la ministre qui décide je veux
revenir sur les dossiers de demande de
subvention qui ont été déposés
préalablement à l'appel à projet parce
que ça nous a fait un peu sortir de de
l'appel à projet certains ont été
validés lors du comité de programmation
du 13 avril validé
et ensuite pour certains d'entre eux ils
ont été basculés dans le fond Marianne
donc je rappelle qu'il est mis en place
officiellement le 20 avril
au final est-ce que c'est pas d'une
certaine manière contraire à l'esprit
qui préside à la création du fond
Marianne dont l'objectif est de lutter
contre toutes les formes de séparatisme
notamment par la voie digitale et
numérique
je comprends pas le sens de votre
question parce que la question vous avez
des dossiers qui sont validés dans le
comité de programmation du 13 avril ça
veut dire que c'était plutôt du gré
c'est ce que vous avez expliqué le vin
avril vous lancez le fond Marianne et
par un tour je suis pas assez de passe
une analyse très aboutie enfin certains
des dossiers qui avaient été retenus
dans le je dis bien retenu dans le
comité programmation du 13 avril
finalement bascule ensuite dans le fond
Marianne or l'esprit du fond Marianne il
est aussi différent il est de faire
autrement d'identifier des acteurs
associatifs
sur des actions nouvelles alors ça peut
les actions des acteurs associatifs
anciens ou nouveau mais vous en avez qui
viennent d'obtenir un accord sur la
communauté de programmation
vous voyez c'est la raison pour laquelle
quand je vous disais le bilan est en
demi-tain on a l'impression qu'il y a dû
rattrapage ça manque de lisibilité et de
force en tous les cas dans le dans le
projet me semble-t-il
non
votre votre question c'est savoir si je
trouve que ça manque de lisibilité dans
le processus
de l'esprit oui enfin je sais pas
comment il faut que je vous pose la
question
non monsieur rapporteur à ce moment-là
moi je suis pas dans les réunions qui
décident de passer tel association de
d'un financement habituel à un appel à
projet ou qui leur propose de le faire
néanmoins
aujourd'hui je ne suis pas choquée par
le fait que on est des acteurs avec
lesquels on travaille habituellement et
qu'on les flèche vers l'appel à projet
c'est la question
je trouve que je vous ai senti beaucoup
plus parfois
motivé et convaincu je trouve que là
vous êtes plutôt sur d'une seule mère un
faux plat
parce que il y a un vrai mélange qui ne
sert pas la cause pour laquelle le fond
Marianne a été mis en oeuvre en tous les
cas moi c'est ce que j'en ai compris
après coup puisque je l'avais pas suivi
de très près au départ voilà je pense
qu'il y a un problème de ligne
directrice vous avez un sujet avec le
secteur associatif qui n'est évidemment
pas forcément facile
à mettre en action parce que on a
compris la complexité du label de l'État
qui a des difficultés
de communiquer et de pénétrer voilà
ces milieux qui ne sont pas conformes je
dirais à l'esprit des valeurs de la
République mais entre tout ça pour moi
on sent du cafouillage du mélange des
genres et j'ai encore à cette heure-ci
j'essaie de suivre votre parcours mais
je peux vous avouer parfois entre vous
le cabinet le cpdr des fonctionnaires
qui sont rentrés dans votre cabinet mais
qui sont donc dans le cabine mais qui
sont les anciens fonctionnaires et puis
tout le processus se déroule avec le
fond Marianne mise en oeuvre enfin
officiellement annoncé le 20 avril
terminé le 10 mai à comité de sélection
qui sélectionne mais la ministre peut et
je l'entends mais on a une difficulté
parce que vous nous dites que vous tenez
à l'écart mais quand même vous rendez
des décisions de revenir sur au moins
une décision du comité de sélection je
voudrais juste savoir si c'est une
procédure assez habituelle ou si c'était
un cas unique par rapport à votre
expérience
sur le rapporteur je trouve que chacun
est en réalité dans son rôle c'est à
dire que le ministre impulse la
politique publique la représente la
défend
on est en égarant on rencontre ce que je
fais aujourd'hui devant vous et que je
fais à d'autres
occasions et que l'administration
ensuite met en oeuvre suit administre le
fait qu'il y ait des membres de cabinets
qui soient antérieurement membres
d'administration oui c'est très
classique et l'administration
aujourd'hui et remplie de remplir en
tout cas il y a beaucoup dans
l'administration dans un membre de
cabinets ce sont des des trajectoires de
carrière classique
madame la ministre
alors des questions sur le suivi de
manière assez rapide d'abord votre
implication dans le suivi de la
réalisation des projets par les
différentes associations est-ce que vous
avez rencontré certaines d'entre elles
dans la pour vous tenir informé c'est
dans le suivi de trucs ou pas du tout
est-ce que vous considérez
l'administration qui devait suivre pas
vous avez vous revu monsieur Sifaoui
dans la phase
discutée en tout cas aujourd'hui vous le
savez sur la réalisation
est-ce que vous avez été est-ce que vous
avez eu des remontées de difficultés
rencontrez avec certaines associations
durant la période où vous étiez au
ministère
monsieur le Président me remonte je n'ai
aucune remontée de difficultés
d'association d'aucune sorte jusqu'à
l'article du journal Marianne avant cela
et donc récent avant cela pendant toute
la durée du moment où je suis ministre
c'est-à-dire jusqu'en mai 2022 à aucun
moment on ne fait état d'aucune
difficulté rencontrée avec les
associations donc le ministre n'est pas
en charge du contrôle des associations
il y a un contrôle qui manifestement est
effectué c'est ce qui établisse les
différentes déclarations des uns et des
autres en tout cas ce n'est pas le
ministre qui procède à ce contrôle et il
n'y a auprès de moi aucune remontée
d'aucune difficulté de mise en oeuvre
avec ses associations
comment dire
oui en droit
vous avez c'est possible ce que vous
dites est possible et si vous le dites
sincèrement c'est vrai
mais ce qui est étonnant
là où on a du mal c'est si vous voulez
c'est pas une opération comme les autres
c'est bien pour ça d'ailleurs qu'il y a
un débat national un peu là-dessus bien
pour ça qu'il y a des gens qui qui
s'intéressent à ce sujet qui qui
s'interroge c'est que c'est pas un débat
lorsque
lorsqu'on vous faites par exemple vous
subventionnez des associations dans le
cadre du du fond de la prévention de la
délinquance l'essentiel des montants
il n'y a pas derrière de connotation il
y a pas de sujet lorsqu'on est sur le
fond Marianne vous vous auriez pu pour
dire les choses autrement vous aviez
déjà des dépenses qui est concernaient
le sujet vous auriez pu dire j'augmente
les budgets j'ai demandé à mon
administration de mettre plus d'argent
sur ces sur ces moyens liés finalement à
la réponse sur les réseaux sociaux
ça pouvait être ça
et c'était un des éléments de votre plan
tout à fait pas de problème et ça aurait
soulevé aucune question mais vous allez
sur les plateaux télé vous faites des
interviews sur le fond de mariage et
vous faites le lien entre ce qui s'est
passé en octobre 2020 et le fond mariage
et du coup vous connotez votre action ça
devient une action
qui socialement a du sens qui répond à
des angoisses des français quand même ce
qui s'est passé n'est pas rien et vous
faites une réponse politique argumentée
en mettant ce fond Marianne nous vous
étonnez pas après que tout le monde
s'intéresse à qu'est-ce que c'est devenu
le fond Marianne parce que c'est pas une
subvention du fi PDR c'est
c'est une subvention fléchée du qui
n'est pas présenté comme ça qui est
présenté comme la création d'un fond et
qu'il y a une histoire et bien cette
histoire d'une certaine façon elle
appelle et ce qui m'étonne dans votre
réponse je vous le dis c'est que vous me
dites pas pour démarrer ma
responsabilité je reviens toujours nous
on est il y a pas de culpabilité chez
nous il y a de la responsabilité
la responsabilité des lieux vous avez la
responsabilité vous avez fait naître une
idée un concept une réponse politique et
derrière vous nous dites je la suis pas
c'est ça que vous venez de me répondre
je vais vous le dire et c'est grave ça
vous nous dites c'est l'administration
l'administration est chargée de charger
de regarder que financièrement les
choses se passent bien ça c'est pas
votre problème mais quand même le
contenu les éléments est-ce que ça sert
à quelque chose
ça c'est vous quoi et vous l'avez même
d'ailleurs dit vous-même
vous portez les politiques publiques et
si on regarde ce que vous avez porté
comme politique publique à ce moment-là
je dirais presque c'est pas pour des
questions de mon temps mais pour des
questions de contenu c'est vous qui
c'est le fond mariage qui qui est
finalement votre action symbolique et il
y a rien de pire que le symbole quand on
est sur des actions symboliques il faut
qu'elle marche du feu de dieu faut que
ça fonctionne de A à Z et il faut que
vous ayez un regard attentif et là aussi
vous avez ici devant vous des gens qui
ont été élus locaux ils savent que le
sujet sur lequel ils sont pris c'est pas
le sujet qui fait la moitié de leur
budget
c'est quelquefois c'est une bricole mais
on va dire mais là pourquoi vous avez
financé tel truc que tu as l'association
et et dites-nous à quoi ça sert
c'est toujours sur les détails et là
vous nous faites une réponse technique
et j'oserais dire madame la ministre qui
manque un peu le cœur
voilà vous avez pas suivi cette affaire
et c'est presque pire que ça quand on va
sur la suite au moment de transmettre à
votre successeur personne n'est au
courant du sujet fabuleux il est même
pas dans le dossier ministre nous entend
dire donc du début à la fin on a
l'impression que c'est lancé et une fois
que c'est lancé qu'on a dit voilà ce
qu'on va faire tout le reste
ça vous concerne pas alors j'aimerais
que vous ne répondiez à ça parce que ça
c'est extrêmement dérangeant monsieur le
Président je vais t'acheter de vous
répondre
et de changer votre votre impression
même si c'est par nature subjective et
l'impression que vous avez du cœur ou du
de la tonalité que j'utilise pour pour
vous répondre et par nature la vôtre et
parfaitement légitime je veux commencer
par dire que je ne me suis à aucun
moment étonné qu'on s'intéresse à
l'utilisation des crédits du fond
Marianne non seulement je m'en suis pas
étonné ou offusqué mais plus que cela
dès le premier contact avec un
journaliste d'investigation du journal
Marianne sur ce sujet je ne suis plus
membre du gouvernement mais je lui
réponds et je lui réponds que
à ma connaissance ce sont des
informations des demandes d'information
légitimes et que le ministère est fondé
à lui apporter les réponses et
d'ailleurs à ce moment là et je le dis
pour répondre à votre interpellation
monsieur le Président le la journaliste
nous dit qu'elle veut la liste des
bénéficiaires du fond Marianne et je lui
réponds qu'il faut que le ministère la
lui donne parce que à mon sens ce n'est
pas confidentiel et c'est le fait qu'il
y ait un délai pour répondre qui amène à
ce moment-là à dire qu'il y a une
opacité et qu'il y a quelque chose de
sous donc moi je suis non seulement pas
choqué qu'on s'intéresse à
l'organisation du fond Marianne mais
j'en suis demandeuse moi je suis choquée
quand je vois à quel point des missions
qui ont été confiées des attentes fortes
qui ont été portées en toute conscience
vis-à-vis de certains partenaires non en
réalité pas donné lieu à des actions
concrètes derrière tels que l'établi le
rapport de l'igéa bien sûr ça me choque
bien sûr je me sens flouée quand je
découvre cela dans la presse
d'investigation à un moment je ne suis
pas du tout membre du gouvernement à
aucun ministère quand je suis interrogée
ne pas faire les contrôles monsieur le
Président ne signifie pas et pardon si
je me suis mal exprimé ne signifie pas
que je ne sois pas intéressé à cette
politique publique ce que je vous dis et
pour répondre le plus factuellement et
rationnellement et matériellement
possible aux questions qui ne sont
posées depuis ce matin sur ce sujet
c'est que j'essaie de vous apporter des
éléments matériels et que non je n'ai
pas suivi l'utilisation des crédits n'y
contrôler les associations puisque ce
n'était pas le rôle du ministre ça ne
veut pas dire que je mens des intéresse
il est vrai et juste de dire que j'ai
beaucoup communiqué sur le fond Marianne
je pense pas faux de dire que je
communique beaucoup sur toutes les
politiques publiques que je porte on
peut trouver que c'est bien ou que c'est
mal mais c'est ainsi
l'absence de communication une fois
l'annonce faite de la création du fort
Marianne
quasiment l'absence de communication
jusqu'à ce que votre départ sur la mise
en œuvre les choix et puis le projet
avance et le gouvernement par ce choix
de lien avec le monde associatif
affirme une volonté la traduit
concrètement deux choses d'abord je
voudrais poursuivre les réponses à
monsieur le Président si vous me le
permettez parce qu'il y a deux sujets
sur lesquels je souhaite pouvoir
apporter des réponses d'abord sur vous
me dites monsieur le Président qu'on
aurait pu renforcer les moyens par
ailleurs en termes de réponse à
l'attentat terrible qui s'est produit en
octobre 2020 je veux dire que les moyens
ils ont été renforcés j'évoquais les
moyens humains de Pharos j'évoquais les
moyens humains de l'ucider je crois pas
avoir dit ça alors il me semble sauf si
jamais compris que vous avez dit qu'en
réponse je crée le fond Marianne et que
j'aurais pu plutôt dire en réponse nous
allons augmenter les moyens vous auriez
pu faire
je veux dire vous auriez pu le faire de
manière plus discrète si je puis dire
euh simplement dire en termes
d'interview de ou de communication
écouter il y a des fonds qui sont déjà
dédiés à ces opérations on va les
pousser les augmenter et en rester là
sans créer même le nombre de Marianne
vous voyez ce que je veux dire d'accord
à ce moment-là c'était une opération
plus discrète et je vous dirai en
conclusion que je pense que ça aurait
été sans doute une meilleure solution
mais ça se défend parfaitement j'entends
d'ailleurs qu'elle a été débattue je
veux dire au sein du gouvernement et
dans vos services elle a été débattue la
question de savoir s'il fallait
simplement pousser le curseur ou s'il
fallait créer une image voilà et le ma
question portait sur dès l'instant où on
crée une image
c'est comment la fait vivre cette image
je vais aller lourde cette image c'est
ça qui est c'est ça c'est l'événement de
référence qui est lourd voilà et quand
vous voyez et c'est pour ça que je viens
sur cette question qui peut paraître
morale d'une certaine façon mais moi
quand je lis aujourd'hui que la famille
Patty refuse que de lier son nom au fond
Marianne du fait des
discussions en cours ça ça me fait mal
voyez parce que je ça veut dire qu'à un
moment donné il y a eu un abandon de un
abandon du lien relationnel vous voyez
ce que je veux dire et c'est majeur dans
la vie
d'abord monsieur le Président je
[Musique]
d'abord monsieur le Président en ce qui
concerne l'attentat de 2020 je veux dire
que ça ne procède pas à la décision de
lancer une action de contredours mais ça
il fait écho parce que très brève là
dessus le terroriste en zorof le
terroriste qui a commis l'attentat
contre le professeur Samuel Paty le
terrible attentat qui a été qui a été
commis il se serait radicalisé disent
les enquêteurs en ligne en consultant
des réseaux sociaux et c'est pourquoi ça
fait quoi à cette action et ça vient
tristement être dramatiquement illustré
les alertes que les services portent et
la nécessité
d'accélérer et d'avancer sur ce sujet
vous y avez fait directement un lien
quoi voilà bien sûr parce que c'est mise
en s'est mise au regard et c'est hélas
l'illustration de ce que Gilles qui est
belle appelle le djihadisme d'atmosphère
qui vient de façon terrible et
dramatique être illustré le discours des
Mureaux du président de la République
précèdent à cela donc c'est un sujet qui
est déjà
identifié pour nous des travaux qui sont
lancés sur sur ce sujet à ce moment-là
en ce qui concerne le dossier ministre
vous avez parfaitement raison monsieur
le Président le fond Marianne d'après
les éléments que j'ai ni figure pas je
tiens à dire que ce n'est pas le
ministre qui fait le dossier ministre
pour le nouveau ministre qui arrive non
c'est important monsieur le Président on
est d'accord mais ça ça montre quelque
chose ça ça dit quelque chose de
l'importance des choses et l'important
des choses vous l'avez dit c'est vous
qui les pulsez c'est votre
responsabilité politique d'impulser il y
a des sujets qui vous tiennent à cœur et
sincèrement la laïcité c'est pas la
première fois enfin je veux dire il y a
des années que vous avez terminé sur le
sujet donc il y a pas de il y a pas de
doute sur votre voilà crédibilité sur le
sur ce point mais à un moment donné on
crée un faux Marianne il n'y a pas de
suivi vous nous dites pendant la période
où vous êtes ministre bon ben c'est le
vous en occupez pas enfin vous en parlez
pas
dit je ne m'occupe pas de son mariage
alors si je peux répondre mais vous avez
répondu ce qu'on veut dire
de répondre moi je veux enfin je reste
très longtemps si vous voulez mais
l'audition
donc soyez comment dire bon alors
je pense être très respectueuse mais ce
rapporteur dans mes réponses dans le
temps de réponse voilà
mais écoutez simplement dire et je
conçois que ce ne soit pas la réponse
que vous attendiez mais dans
l'interpellation qui m'est faite
avec intérêt merci monsieur le Président
donc je vous ai dit je prends toute ma
responsabilité et rien que ma
responsabilité quand ma successeur est
nommée je ne suis plus au gouvernement
chez d'autres activités ailleurs je ne
suis plus fondée à donner des consignes
à l'administration et ce serait le
contraire qu'il serait reproché
les questions parce que vous avez comme
je vous ai posé une question vous êtes
revenu sur la question précédente donc
invité si vous voulez bien les longueurs
voilà il y a eu une forte annonce
puissante communication et après plus
rien oui je voulais répondre bien sûr
merci monsieur le rapporteur
comme une question au gouvernement
simplement vous dire que il n'y avait
pas plus rien et il y a matérialité dans
les échanges de mails entre mon cabinet
et moi-même et des notes dans lesquelles
nous voulons relancer le fond Marianne
il y a une note de projet suite à
demande de ma part et à échange et suite
justement à discussion avec le cabinet
l'administration sur ce sujet l'un de
mes conseillers prépare un futur appel à
projet pour l'année qui suit sur le fond
Marianne donc nous voulons nous
entendons poursuivre cette politique
publique d'accord mais donc vous
conviendrez et vous ne m'avez pas
démenti qu'il n'y a pas de communication
particulière après le lancement il y a
l'annonce du fond Marianne il y a la
sélection le projet
vit sa vie il y a plus de communication
voilà il n'a plus une bénéficie plus du
même portage et surtout du même éco
médiatique puisque par l'annonce
l'annonce médias et l'annonce fond
Marianne vous l'avez d'ailleurs expliqué
c'est une ambition politique d'un combat
que vous menez contre le discours
séparatiste en lien avec le numérique et
le secteur associatif voilà je vais très
rapide dans ma réponse monsieur le
rapporteur en deux points
encore plus rapide d'abord c'est pas
parce qu'il y a pas de communication qui
a pas de suivi j'ai des je demande je le
dis je ne désintéresse pas du sujet il y
a des points d'étape que je demande et
donc je ne suis pas les subventions mais
je suis le dossier du fond Marianne
première chose et deuxième chose je
n'apprends à personne le système
médiatique et bien évidemment quand un
ministre fait des annonces qui sont
susceptibles de générer des dépêches et
des reprises cela intéresse les les
différentes les différents médias mais
quand on veut communiquer sur des bilans
c'est beaucoup plus c'est beaucoup moins
jugé moins intéressant et c'est plus
difficile de surcroît qu'on les porteurs
de projets ne souhaitent pas apparaître
pour des raisons de sécurité parce que
certains d'entre disent qu'ils sont
assez ça ne nous a pas échappé mais
entre certains
et rien du tout
la preuve le fait qu'il n'y ait même pas
de bilan sur un sujet comme celui-ci et
moi je je suis je m'inscris parfaitement
dans les propos de Claude Raynal
enfin la gravité de l'acte est la
solennité
de la République
lorsqu'on s'est retrouvé
à la Sorbonne pour manifester
l'unité de la République en faveur de ce
combat je dois dire que je le dis après
le fond Marianne tout ça a perdu
beaucoup de consistance voilà c'est tout
moi
puisqu'on arrive à la fin
finalement à ce stade appel à projet
vous venez d'évoquer les conditions dans
lesquelles il s'était organisé déroulée
sélectionner valider
si cette affaire vous feriez la même
chose en mieux vous procéderiez de
quelle manière puisque
peut-être on donnera des orientations à
ce stade étant en responsabilité
toujours et du monde associatif quel est
votre regard
qu'avez-vous à nous dire à cet instant
ce rapporteur plusieurs quelque chose
d'abord
effectivement il est vous l'avez dit
nécessaire de resituer le contexte et
vous l'avez fait donc je n'y reviens pas
il y a évidemment des choses qu'on
aurait pu faire différemment dans la
mesure où on arrive aujourd'hui à
commander un rapport à l'ija vous
arrivez vous-même à lancer une
commission d'enquête et à vous saisir
les prérogatives de contrôle de l'action
du gouvernement par le Parlement
parfaitement légitimement et utilement
sur ce sujet c'est donc il y a eu des
dysfonctionnements dans l'organisation
ou la gestion du fond Marianne moi je
veux être à ce stade prudente pour pas
émettre ici des sentiments ou des
impressions mais je pense qu'il est
effectivement nécessaire d'avoir
peut-être par écrit un certain nombre de
règles de la manière dont les
subventions peuvent être attribuées il
existe déjà des écrits peut-être est-il
nécessaire de les préciser notamment
quand tu as l'organisation des comités
de sélection quant à l'organisation du
et quand aux mesures qu'il est possible
de mettre en place par l'administration
en matière de contrôle
vis-à-vis des organisations qui sont
subventionnées ceci étant avec ma
casquette aujourd'hui secrétaire d'État
chargé de la vie associative je dirais
que c'est une ligne de crête si je
m'extrais du sujet du fond Marianne
parce que la question de la liberté
associative elle me semble fondamentale
et c'est pourquoi d'ailleurs l'une des
associations que vous avez auditionnées
qui a mis en place des vidéos
contestables et contestées et que moi
même je conteste puisqu'elle s'en prend
à des responsables politiques Madame la
Maire de Paris mais pas uniquement
porte-parole du gouvernement ils ont
intérieure moi-même prison la République
etc elle invoque me semble-t-il aussi
cette liberté associative dans les
contenus là il y a une ligne rouge parce
qu'on est sur des contenus politiciens
mais jusqu'où
l'administration et même le ministre
est-il fondé à aller dans le contrôle
des productions d'une association c'est
une vraie question c'est pas une
question rhétorique c'est une vraie
question et c'est pour ça que je suis
sincère cèrement très preneuse des
retours et des préconisations et
instructions vous donnerez à l'issue de
cette commission
merci madame la ministre nous allons
conclure donc nous allons prendre deux
questions alors je vais demander aux
auteurs comme d'habitude
d'être trois questions donc rapides
alors Jean-Michel Arnaud Daniel broyier
oui monsieur le Président Monsieur le
rapporteur de la même ministre très
rapidement puisque nos travaux se
concluent
je vais essayer de rester finalement
dans les faits vous avez indiqué madame
la ministre en cours d'audition
aujourd'hui je n'ai passé aucune
commande de faire passer le dossier
c'était le premier dossier de l'US ppm
ensuite
vous avez indiqué lors d'un communiqué
de presse du 7 avril 2023
que toutes les candidatures reçues dans
le cas de l'appel à projet de fonds
Marianne 17 ont été retenus par un
comité de sélection dont le choix s'est
fait via l'administration je vous cite à
la manœuvre dans le respect de toutes
les procédures
enfin cela a été rappelé par le
président le préfet Gravel
a indiqué
confirmer un arbitrage défavorable à
ministre concernant l'association
SOS Racisme bon je comprends la
difficulté du sujet je comprends votre
ligne non pas de défense mais
d'explication ceci étant dit les faits
sont là il y a des contradictions
majeures sur lesquelles effectivement
notre commission à démontrer et à
révéler les circonstances et je pense
que s'il y a un point sur lequel
j'attends au moins en termes de
conclusion de cette audition
des mots de votre part c'est d'assumer
votre responsabilité il y a eu
manifestement des difficultés de gestion
de ce dossier des imprécisions dans la
méthodologie et des implications à
divers degrés y compris politiques sur
la gestion de ce dossier je crois qu'il
serait bien que ce soit dit clairement
ne serait-ce que par respect pour la la
famille de Samuel Paty et pour la cause
que nous défendons nous défendons nous
défendons tout tous ici qui est
effectivement la défense des valeurs de
la République quel que soit le bon ou
séjour je vous remercie merci
Jean-Michel Daniel broyer puis Thierry
cosit merci Madame la Ministre
l'assassinat de Samuel patine nous a
tous bouleversé parce que la République
est ses valeurs sont notre bien commun
j'ai entendu vos propos et je vais
comprendre sur la différence entre le
rôle d'un ministre et le rôle d'un
cabinet ou d'une administration je ne
comprends pas qu'un ministre ne cherche
pas à entraîner la totalité de la
société française sur un combat aussi
symbolique et du coup il y a une
incohérence pour moi qui est le fait que
vous décidiez de retirer
vous n'avez pas dire tiré mais de ne pas
attribuer de subventions à SOS Racisme
et que vous validiez des associations
dans la fragilité est avérée voire qui
sont créés pour ça et et pour le coup
c'est le rôle d'une ministre je pense
que d'entraîner tout le monde exemple et
je ne comprends pas
ce choix merci Daniel Thierry Cosic
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre depuis le début de l'audition
vous nous avez fait état que
vous n'avez pas ou peu participer au
processus de sélection des associations
par contre j'ai noté moi dans vos
réponses incertains de contradictions et
notamment
au moment où vous dites que 300000 euros
et je crois que vous l'avez écrit c'est
trop c'est que factuellement vous
participez à la décision
également l'arbitrage sur sur la
subvention de 100.000 euros pour SOS
Racisme
j'ai le sentiment que
dans la sélection des associations c'est
mettre à l'honneur la prise de décision
démocratique la transparence et la
délibération sont des piliers qui sont
me semble-t-il au cœur de votre fonction
à la fois en tant que membre du
gouvernement
luttant contre la défiance
institutionnelle et quand cancienne
ministre délégué de la citoyenneté
cependant et ce sera peut-être une forme
de conclusion comment pouvez-vous ne pas
vous interroger et être alerté par
l'absence de critères explicites de
sélection des associations par voie de
cabinet
j'ai le sentiment qu'aujourd'hui on est
dans un processus qui s'apparente à une
véritable chimère j'aurais souhaité
avoir votre sentiment sur sur cela
madame la ministre on va vous proposer
également deux éléments de conclusion à
ce stade
du rapporteur et de moi-même et vous
répondrai si vous voulez bien à
l'ensemble sans d'ailleurs avoir à
distinguer tel ou tel mais peut-être sur
le sur les propos généraux et vous
finirez et vous conclurez vous même
madame
oui madame la ministre peut-être pour
faire deux ou trois observations qui se
traduisent évidemment en question
un certain nombre de questions me
semble-t-il même après votre audition
reste en suspens
vous êtes à l'initiative dans les
conditions qu'on a évoqué de la création
de ce fond et vous êtes en vous avez été
en responsabilité de la mise en œuvre
des projets est-ce que à ce stade vous
pensez que le projet devenu fond
Marianne à remplir pleinement ces
objectifs est-ce que vous pensez qu'il a
été à la hauteur des ambitions fortes
affichées et affirmé par le gouvernement
je le rappelle dans un contexte inédit
et particulièrement grave est-ce que
vous considérez que les procédures ont
bien été respectées qu'elles sont
d'ailleurs en tout point conforme à une
gestion saine et rigoureuse des fonds
publics est-ce que vous pensez en
quelque sorte que le fond Marianne a
bien été
utile dans l'expérience nouvelle
de lien porté par les associations
soutenues par le gouvernement pour
lutter contre les discours séparatistes
et permettez-moi madame la ministre
d'avoir une question
plus personnel parce que je j'ai le
sentiment que vous au long de cette
audition vous vous êtes mise en quelque
sorte en porte-à-faux par rapport au
projet du fond Marianne pourquoi est-ce
que je dis ça c'est parce que vous avez
passé beaucoup de temps
à travers de nombreuses réponses à
expliquer et exprimer que vous vous
étiez tenu à distance
avant
vous êtes toujours à distance vous
n'avez pas d'amis ça j'ai compris que
c'était une réponse à la presse je vais
dire simplement
au moment de la création du fond
vous le validez puis vous tenez à
nouveau à distance vous ne vous
intéressez pas alors
si vous reconnaissez qu'il y a quand
même eu une intercession
défavorable à SOS Racisme et ensuite il
y a plus de communication
est-ce que je me trompe aurais-je mal
compris
alors dans le même sens de quelques mots
puisque aujourd'hui on est vers la fin
de nos auditions vous le savez madame
même si nous avons comme ceifaoui demain
notamment et votre et Madame bacquesse
cet après-midi mais quand même quelques
quelques moules là aussi et question
donc si on reprend un peu les choses on
voit que nos travaux ont montré qu'il y
avait eu des contacts donc en amont de
la création du fond avec différents
acteurs c'est à dire que l'appel à
projet n'a pas consisté à susciter des
candidatures mais en amont un amant du
fond à préparer des candidatures pour
certains c'est ce qui rend le d'ailleurs
le la notion d'iné équitable tout à fait
juste dans l'appréciation de l'IGA des
associations en ont été sélectionnées
donc quelquefois avant l'ouverture de
l'appel à projet sans prendre de
précoler précautions minimale demande
toujours à une association encore plus
quand il s'agit d'une subvention de
nature exceptionnelle quand on est à 300
350 000 euros c'est exceptionnel dans ce
dans ce milieu
et donc sans aucune garantie les
procédures de sélection ont été à
géométrie variable c'est le moins
compliqué c'est une vision délicate de
manière délicate de dire les choses en
fonction des acteurs
et donc effectivement l'hygia dit des
choses tout à fait claires des décisions
ont été prises modifiées en aval du
comité de sélection donc y compris
directement par vous madame la ministre
sous réserve de vos appréciations bien
entendu et cela nous a été confirmé par
votre directeur de cabinet nous l'avons
dit un appel à projet sans grille
d'analyse sans objectivité
des candidatures
est-ce que vous pensez pas que la
politique de lutte contre les discours
séparatistes mérités un peu mieux ne
pensez-vous pas non plus qu'une action
qui entendait donc répondre je reviens
au sujet précédent que j'ai déjà traité
un assassinat horrible perpétrer en
octobre 2020 méritait une mise en œuvre
une attention un suivi précis sérieux
continue
au-delà des responsabilités d'un
secrétaire général qui sont pointés par
l'igéa et donc abîmée continuez vous
vraiment
à dénier toute responsabilité dans ce
fiasco il a fallu que je vous interroge
sur ce point précis pour que vous
reconnaissiez quelques quelques un bout
de responsabilité
ce fiasco il est dû je dis sophiako
parce que il concerne à travers
finalement l'action de deux associations
qui ont été allés encourager monter
spécifiquement pour cela
finalement
alors que les autres finalement les
autres associations c'était des
associations qui étaient déjà des
associations qui travaillaient avec le
secrétariat général
et donc
finalement tout ce qui a été tenté en
terme innovant entre guillemets ben
c'est casser un peu la figure alors
c'est dû à la vitesse sans doute
l'impréparation sûrement à la volonté de
communiquer rapidement c'est une presque
une maladie gouvernementale je parle pas
de ce gouvernement je parle de manière
générale un événement une réponse une
communication c'est vieux comme comme la
politique je suis pas sûr que déjà je
sais pas quoi sous les Grecs on
retrouvait par quelque chose de même
nature donc c'est vieux c'est ancien
comme méthode de fermer est-ce que c'est
aujourd'hui pertinent et en s'appuyant
sur des nouveaux acteurs qui finalement
ont été n'ont pas été encadrés et
aujourd'hui d'ailleurs qui sont mises en
cause par cela même qu'ils les ont créés
un article 40 pour l'une une demande de
remboursement sur quelle base on sait
pas trop mais il me demande de
remboursement à la deuxième
c'est c'est quand même c'est quand même
le signe d'une grande difficulté
je l'ai dit vous auriez pu vous
contenter me semble-t-il d'associer
d'amener les associations déjà connues
déjà sur le terrain à s'intéresser à
votre à votre projet et à développer je
pense que le résultat aurait été sans
doute meilleur et finalement et je
reviens à votre propos introductif
lorsque vous avez dit je salue le
travail des de la majorité des
associations qui font un bon boulot qui
travaille bien dans ce domaine etc et je
partage je partage votre avis nous en
avons croisé quelques-unes beaucoup nous
ont envoyé même leur production vous
voyez de manière à ce que on puisse
regarder concrètement les choses et il y
a des productions qui sont tout à fait
tout à fait intéressantes à regarder des
projets associatifs tout à fait
intéressant mais finalement en
pratiquant ainsi par cet appel à projet
mal géré mal suivi et à cause de ce
projet moi l'impression que vous avez
surtout fragilisé toute cette chaîne
d'acteurs
qui travaillent sur le terrain a dénoncé
des discours des discours séparatifs
depuis des années mais en le faisant
souvent sous l'angle de l'explication du
travail consciencieux sur le terrain de
faire avancer des contribués de lutter
contre le discours séparatiste et qui le
font bien depuis des années et est-ce
que vous avez est-ce que vous avez
conscience que finalement cette
opération on fond Marianne elle
fragilise terriblement cette cette
chaîne de compétences associative qui a
mis du temps à se mettre en place et qui
est une base extrêmement forte et comme
notre collègue le disait il faut pas
jeter tout les bébés avec l'eau du
beurre vous devez repris cette
expression je la reprends à mon compte
également mais malheureusement
le mal est un peu fait même si on espère
que
le temps passant on puisse remonter
remonter les choses mais j'aimerais
avoir votre position là-dessus madame la
ministre et vous nous répondez vos
conclure en même temps de votre point de
vue
pardon de combien de temps est-ce que je
dispose pour vous répondre
pas de faire un résumé à des questions
aussi voilà merci monsieur le Président
d'abord pour vous répondre au global je
redis ce que j'ai dit depuis le début
sur ce sujet c'est à dire que je prends
absolument toute la responsabilité qui
est la mienne c'est à dire la
responsabilité politique je ne m'en suis
jamais dédouanée de cette responsabilité
politique j'ai toujours assumé qu'elles
étaient les décisions les lignes
politiques les commandes politiques
passées je l'ai dit à de nombreuses
reprises pour citer les grands auteurs à
un chef c'est fait pour chez fait donc
Jean d'os bien sûr la responsabilité de
mes décisions mais aussi de celle de mon
directeur de cabinet qui a délégation de
ma signature avec qui j'ai travaillé en
parfaite symbiose et confiance dans dans
les décisions qu'il a pu prendre en mon
nom il était fondé à cela j'ai dit aussi
que je prenais toute ma responsabilité
et rien que ma responsabilité je ne
crois pas je le redis rapidement mais je
le redis je ne crois pas je suis imputer
un dirigeant public un responsable
politique la malversation interne d'une
structure à laquelle il fait confiance
au moment il lui fait confiance quand il
n'a pas de raison à ce moment-là de ne
pas le faire je veux dire que sur
l'attribution des subventions et je
réponds je me répète mais je réponds à
une interpellation je redis que je
n'avais pas d'implication personnelle
que je n'ai pas soutenu de dossier en
particulier je le redis très clairement
et que je n'ai pas pris de décision de
soutien à un dossier sur quelques
raisons personnelles que ce soit que
j'ai en revanche rendu un avis quand on
est venu d'initiative me le solliciter
sur la question du suivi je veux dire
que il y a des communications qui sont
adressées c'est à dire des bilans si on
peut dire en conseil des ministres
notamment en février il y en a une qui
est nommée il y a un suivi étroit de ce
dossier ne pas aller dans ligne
générique depuis des subventions et ne
pas contrôler personnellement le travail
mené par les associations ne signifie
pas qu'il n'y ait pas de suivi du projet
je veux dire que tous les mois j'ai
rendu compte de la lutte contre le
séparatisme et vous avez eu monsieur le
Président la gentillesse de le rappeler
que c'est un sujet qui me tient à cœur
de longue date avant même d'être chargé
de la question de la citoyenneté et qui
est un sujet qui pour moi est
intrinsèquement lié à la question de la
liberté des femmes et de la protection
des femmes et on le voit trop souvent
dans trop d'actualités dans le monde à
quel point les femmes sont les premières
victimes de cette idéologie
séparatiste et islamiste qui menace
encore notre sol alors où nous sommes en
train de parler vous avez fait mention
il a été fait mention et j'en avais fait
moi-même mention de de l'attentat odieux
commis contre le professeur Samuel Paty
j'en garderai toute ma vie et le
souvenir c'est moi qui ai ouvert la CIC
et la cellule en terminale de crise et
je suis allée avec le président de la
République et le ministre de l'Intérieur
sur place et tous ceux qui ont été en
responsabilité quel que soit leur degré
de responsabilité au moment d'attentat
terroriste n'oublie jamais ce qu'ils ont
vu senti et entendu sur place quand ils
s'y rendu donc bien évidemment et comme
chacun ici je trouve que c'est une lutte
prioritaire et qui doit continuer bien
sûr de d'être mené dans les réponses que
j'ai pu apporter j'ai insisté sur le
rôle que j'avais ou que je n'avais pas
parce que c'est les réponses aux
questions mais aussi parce que j'ai pu
être mise en cause à tort par voie de
presse de fait qu'ici vous n'avez pas
relié bien sûr je distingue les deux et
je n'ai pas voulu répondre à la presse
par l'intermédiaire de la commission
mais j'ai voulu être factuel et clair
pour vous donner tous les éléments sur
sur ces sujets là
[Musique]
je veux redire peut-être parce que on
est passé rapidement sur ce sujet je
suis brève et je le fais vraiment en
quelques minutes mais redire que je n'ai
pas non plus financé de contenu
politique c'est la question n'a pas été
posée j'ai pas financé de contenu
politique en période électorale
contrairement à ce qui a été écrit dans
la presse à un moment il est aujourd'hui
démontré que c'est faux et d'autres
articles sont venus l'infirmier je le
dis parce que quand on est
successivement accusé d'un peu tout et
son contraire dans la presse y compris
de délits et qu'en fait il est démontré
semaine après semaine qu'en fait ce
n'est pas du tout ça la question qui est
posée c'est assez différent que de se
demander si un appel à projet est assez
long et assez bien ficelé ou de se
demander s'il y a des délices sont des
choses différentes il a été soulevé
qu'il restait des questions en suspens
c'est juste moi-même je suis très
preneuse d'avoir les réponses des
questions qui restent en suspens je suis
pas omnisciente ni il y a en ce moment
votre commission d'enquête il y a un
deuxième rapport de l'hygia qui arrive
il y a une instruction ouverte du PNF
sur une association en particulier je
n'y reviens pas vous le savez eu égard
la préparation des pouvoirs je sais pas
fondée à commenter cette instruction qui
relève exclusivement de la justice pour
une affaire en cours mais je veux dire
et ce sera ma conclusion qu'il y a eu
cinq mois de travail pour aboutir au
fond de mariage que le l'impulsion
politique qui est donné par nature
contestable nous sommes en démocratie
elle peut l'être elle est et elle a
parfaitement le droit de l'être que la
méthode au delà de l'impulsion peut
parfaitement être remise en cause et
améliorer et clarifier elle le sera je
n'en doute pas et personnellement quel
que soit les responsabilités que j'ai ou
que je n'ai pas à occuper dans l'avenir
je mettrai en oeuvre les recommandations
qui seront
indiquées en matière de liens sur la
question des subventions et en
conclusion je veux très simplement
redire d'autres l'ont dit je l'avais dit
également précédemment mais je veux
redire et ce sera ma conclusion le
soutien que j'apporte à toutes les
personnes qui sont aujourd'hui des
combattants et des combattants de la
lutte contre l'islamisme radical en
France et dans le monde toute personne
qui ne serait-ce que prend la parole
publiquement pour contredire et pour
pourfendre l'idéologie de l'islamisme le
fait au péril de sa vie et on voit bien
à quel point aujourd'hui notamment des
lauréats du fond Marianne qui ont mené
une action remarquable et qui parfois
veut une antériorité d'action de
bénévolement pendant des années pour
apporter un discours face à la
radicalisation des jeunes le font
aujourd'hui sous le coup de menaces
d'insultes permanence de
cyber-harcèlement de menaces pour leur
vie pour leurs proches et je tiens ici à
leur apporter très clairement et très
fermement mon soutien le plus absolu et
le plus inconditionnel je vous remercie
merci Madame la Ministre merci à vos
collaborateurs et bonne journée à tous